I don't know where this is.
I'm just gonna ignore.
There you go.
Now it should be on the game.
I'm scared.
I don't know what this is.
You can wishlist a game right now.
Pretty sure you get some goodies if you wishlist as well, right?
Yeah.
Right now.
And watch the stream.
The stream where it drops.
For keys to pay.
Now the best thumbnail.
There you go.
I'm a professional.
Is it working?
Yay!
Okay.
I'm pinning it.
Wow.
How's that?
Did it work?
Yes.
Wait, they got one of the Osu goats.
Yeah, they got a lot of Osu players.
Oh, they got MREC?
Oh.
No, MREC is someone...
It's like... That's an OG.
That's like Jesus.
We have BCMC in here too.
Oh no, Jesus.
I like to play music.
There we go.
It's on Fate Trigger now.
For reals.
For real, real?
For reals, reals.
Oh wait, we have a full team now.
I've been here.
Oh wait.
Have you though?
Is that like a...
Is that a dropbox though?
That's why they were talking in the Discord.
Hey, is Yazdesk Refraz you?
Is there a dropbox?
Is it just a free-for-all?
I think it's a free-for-all.
It's a free-for-all.
I was watching the tournament and it's been free-for-all.
You guys want to hot drop?
I like... I like dropping on the ship, dude.
Let's hot drop on Fun and then teabag him.
Oh, we're entering.
Oh, he's got a filter tower.
Alright.
I got it.
I'm confirming my tier.
By the way, to my chat, I have to be DokiBird too.
Cause someone took DokiBird.
So there's a DokiBird one out there.
How do we know you're not the clone?
I'm literally sponsored.
If the real DokiBird was here...
He would be sponsored.
I don't know.
You could have just fooled the devs.
That seems fake.
These fake DokiBirds are pretty crafty.
Say something real Doki would say.
Say something...
Saibao.
Fucking ban her devs.
RPR taught me that word.
And what does that word mean?
I don't even watch TikTok.
What does it mean, RPR?
What does Saibao mean?
I don't know.
I was trying to figure that out on my own.
I'm too old for TikTok.
I'm calling Doki a bitch.
Yeah.
I play Marvel Rivals.
My silly math group.
I'm gonna get cancelled.
I'm surprised you haven't yet.
I'm gonna relinquish this.
Oh, he has the EU privilege.
That's why.
Oh, yeah.
They're uncancellable.
Because he's racist.
What the hell do you mean?
I've never said anything cancelable in my life.
He said the C word.
What did I say?
Yeah, he said the C word.
Blanker.
Yeah, and he said he got the pass.
But I don't think he did.
He's a VTuber.
He's got the pass for Blanker.
Dude, listen.
I might not have aim assist.
Yeah, I can tell.
You literally have less damage than me last game.
There's a team back on the red thing back there.
I might die first, guys.
T to detach.
I'm out of here.
Oh, okay.
I got my Cantius.
Let's go.
The auto loot is in my favor.
No gun, no gun.
If you don't know the OP guns yet, it's Cantius, Gladiator, the auto shotgun, and the Jackson.
Yay.
I got my Cantius and my Gladiator.
Yeah, I'm playing Gladiator auto shotgun every game.
There's a sniper.
Oh, wait.
There's another Cantius here.
So his shotgun just like...
The auto shotgun is really good for Sinric too.
I play it on this character because like my goal is to go in and go one for one.
Like I...
Because of my ult, you know?
So I need to go in.
I can't find armor.
I have white armor.
Oh, wait.
There's houses down here.
I'm going to go get a little.
Oh, yeah.
For those who don't know what this game is.
It's basically anime girl battle royale.
Time for a great game.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
And you can download the...
You can wishlist...
I can't download it.
You can wishlist the game right now.
And sign up for the closed beta.
And if you watch our streams, you might get the drops for the keys.
All right, guys.
I need you guys to pick it up on the show.
Oh, my God.
Backpack.
Blue backpack.
Exploding in the background.
That was a door, my bad.
I found a gladiator.
Oh, my God.
We're all sponsored here.
And I got auto shotgun.
All right.
We got some good stuff.
I got gladiator auto shotgun.
Fly over to you guys.
We need a whip.
We do need a car, though.
I got three times on my gladi.
Is that...
Yeah, it's good.
The gladi...
The gladi is a beam.
It just got nerfed, but it's still really good.
All right.
Blue armor.
I think I need a compensator for you.
It just got nerfed.
There's a sniper here if anyone wants it.
Oh, there's 3x.
There's a 3x here, too.
These items should be shared with everyone.
I can get a sniper.
I got one.
Here's a...
Auto shotty.
There's also DMR.
Who's gonna be using the auto shotty?
Yeah, I'm good on DMR.
Meh.
Is there fall damage?
I don't think so.
There's a purple mag for that DMR if you want.
Guys, is there fall damage?
Yes.
No, no.
No.
Okay.
There's fall damage.
There's literally fall damage.
Why are you lying?
From high enough, there's fall damage.
How high, though?
There's not.
I've literally pulled mid-air and jumped down and didn't take full damage.
Yeah.
We could...
We could go up here.
Up here.
Yeah, let's loot.
Yeah, we gotta try to get purples.
Get purples and juice up on school piercers and shit.
Let's get school piercers and, like, all that shit.
Take this car, though.
I didn't see...
Yeah, I will.
I didn't see if anyone landed up here.
But there could be.
I don't...
I don't see either, but...
We just...
I know that there was people to our west, but yeah.
Should we get an armor car?
Or should we all...
One early fight wouldn't be bad.
Probably everyone in blue armors and shit.
That's true.
I mean, we could...
I mean, if we lose, though...
That'd be a free fight.
I never lose.
I feel like I should not be...
...allowed to drive.
I feel like, as the guy with the most ping, I think you're right.
Take this fucking driver.
He's driving into a frickin' wall.
I don't think there's anyone there.
I'm just doing extra...
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Pick up smokes, guys.
Smokes is real important.
He's...
He's leaving us.
Incendiaries are also insane.
Yeah.
34 left us.
Flashbang is not so much.
You guys were looting.
I thought we robbed you.
Nothing picked up on skin.
Oh, I don't have enough to craft.
Now we're just gonna rob him to him.
What if we get shot in the cross?
I'm the support.
Alright.
We can take this TP to mainline, so we can be here forever.
Apparently, people are saying there's no fall damage, but you can fall off the map.
Yeah, but if you do that, it means you just didn't press space bar.
Oh, did you actually see the packet loss?
I'm pretty sure it's impossible to fly off the map because the game stops you from it.
You can literally glide under the map.
If final circle's near the edge, you just jump off and glide.
I don't like stall time.
Wait, really?
Yeah, people do that.
People are doing that in higher ranks.
Oh, there's a- Isn't there like a teleporter thing you can put down there?
There's an item.
There's an item, yeah.
It's from care packages and the harmonizer.
There's a 4X here if anyone needs it.
Emergency TP.
There's a purple.
Yeah, yeah.
That TP's broken for endgame.
There's a purple helmet, too.
Purple, purple, purple.
Purple.
Purple, all purple.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, grab this armor.
There is...
Does anyone need a 4x?
Wait, this space is insane.
What the hell?
Yeah, there's this.
I got a lot of shit there.
This building's nuts.
There's another purple on the roof up here.
Purple sniper mag.
Purple AR mag.
Two purple AR mags.
And there's another purple here.
Ah, we're good.
We should just farm money now.
Yeah, we just need our upgrades.
I have money.
We ideally want to play for the harmonizers as soon as they come up on ring close.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Harmonize.
We've got a minute and a half.
I'm sticking close to you guys.
I'm going to take a car over to the upgrades.
Oh, I want to.
No, take me with you.
Take me with you.
I have enough upgrade too.
What is harmonizer chat?
It's this.
It's the...
Also, you can drop your extra money.
Oh, it's not this, guys.
You can drop your extra money to teammates, by the way.
What is the harmonizer?
Harmonizer, you know the...
You know the big three-story building that has, like, got the in it?
When you open inventory, bottom right supply point.
That's the money.
That's the harmonizer.
How much money, you guys?
I only have 60.
There's one more impact mod here if you want it.
I have $30.
$30.
Yeah, impact is good.
That's first aid.
Wait, I can buy a gun that heals.
Yeah, do it.
Can I have some money, guys?
Uh...
No.
Wait, I have 30.
I thought I'd give you 30.
Here.
Here's 30.
I need 10 more for a gun upgrade.
I don't get what I need.
I'll give you 10 here.
Good boy.
Okay.
Alright.
Shut the fuck up.
Dude, he was crouched on the ground waiting for it.
And he has, like, a little dog mask on, too.
I'm gonna get mulliganed.
Alright, where do we go?
Let's go.
Can we just hit the teleporter?
Alright, let me...
Let me...
Let me get the...
Get out, Drew.
Get out of it.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you're right.
Here, RPI.
I'll jump.
You do it.
I don't know why you wanted this one in particular so much.
It was mine.
I parked it.
You parked it, bro.
What are you sure for?
Where are we going?
We'll hang out, like...
No one pinged the giant thing.
I'm gonna grab this.
I was like, why are we driving away from it?
I mean, that portal is a portal, too.
I mean, I feel like we should have went through the portal.
Yeah, we're just gonna play...
We can just play around the portal and wait for the zone to pop and see where we gotta go.
Well, he meant the big portal.
What's the big portal?
Oh, that portal.
What's this?
I'm just gonna hang out here.
Wait for...
Wait to see zone.
There's...
Oh, dude, I'm gonna adjust the volume, everybody.
Oh, my God.
I thought this said Mount Femdom.
It says Mount Fenton.
What?
Are you okay?
Did you get a...
Yeah, did you get a stroke just now?
I don't even want to know what's in your Twitter feed, bro.
You think it's Mount Femdom?
I mean, he...
I don't even use Twitter, man.
What's on your TikTok?
What do you get on your TikTok?
I don't even use TikTok.
How did you get Saipao from?
You said you got Brigger on it.
You said TikTok.
Yeah, you said TikTok to us.
It's like all YouTube shorts are just reused TikToks.
You don't know that.
They could be YouTube shorts original.
Which is just TikTok on them.
How do you know that?
You have to watch TikTok to know that.
Because it says on the bottom of the short, you can see the TikTok thing.
There's TikTok.
It's called a for you page for a reason.
If you're seeing that, then that means you're living.
Okay, you guys are making me fun for not using social media and being healthy in the brain, dude.
Thanks.
You healthy in the brain?
I don't play VR chat.
I drink in there.
I don't.
You play VR chat.
Oh, that's not playing.
That's not playing.
Social media.
Jen talks about drinking two seconds later, which is literally rotting your brain.
Yeah.
And what's wrong with alcohol?
I like it.
To be fair.
He is European.
Breathing air is bad for you.
He is salvic.
Harmonizer is spawned.
So what is the Harmonizer?
It's the big circle on the map.
Oh.
Should we get another strong boy?
Strong vehicle?
Maybe.
We have to turn around.
I'm going the wrong way.
I'll take it.
Why do we fall?
Oh, wait.
We're going to get another CP.
You're just like right behind him.
How are you so fast?
There might be a team at the Harmonizer already.
Oh, my God.
Imagine they're camping us.
I didn't kill the effect.
I had a game where I came through one of these TPs and people set up a roadblock.
Oh.
Should have had vehicles in front of it.
Very good.
That sounds scary.
Is it safe?
Oh, it's safe.
Oh, my God.
You come out fast out of that one.
There's no one on this armor.
Are you guys okay?
Like, this is a team game, bro.
Stop pushing me.
We're doing bumper cars right now.
I haven't even touched you, bro.
Yeah.
Why are you...
Why are you so insulted?
I'm just giving...
What the fuck is going on?
Did you see Humby killed like 80 people?
Well, he just killed one squad, yeah.
Yeah.
I think that this...
I think there's no one here, because I'm pretty sure the beam is a different color if there's people here.
So, we should be fine.
I thought green means they're taking it.
That was it?
I don't know.
No, no, no, no.
There's no one in there.
I mean, I can just scan.
Just give it a scan.
Yeah, give it a scan.
You're the only one that's played the most out of all of us.
Oh.
Yeah, we're good.
We'll start capping.
What color is it when you're taking it?
Liar.
It's like red or orange or something.
Okay.
Wait, let me look now.
I'm going to sit on the roof if you guys want to stay in the bottom floor.
Okay, I'll be here.
You have to stay in the bottom floor in the circle.
Okay, I'm in.
Okay, I'm...
Wait, use cars as blockaded.
Oh, that's true.
Where's our other car?
I don't know.
You're just going to be throwing them bitches around.
Alright.
I'm harmonizing.
Wait, me too.
I think they sped up the cap speed for this because it used to be really slow.
Yeah, I remember.
Yeah, yeah.
Is there anything good?
I was slow.
No.
I picked it all up.
I'm harmonizing.
We're kind of centered so we don't have to worry too much for it.
I hope I don't get shot at.
Yeah, reach on.
Cause I'm tabbing out.
Is the red shotgun good?
Red shotgun?
I haven't seen a care package shotgun.
Isn't there one?
There's a SMG, LMG, Sniper, and GL.
Oh, it's GL what I'm thinking about.
Oh, that's the gold package.
That's the gold package.
Get back.
We should pick that up.
It's pretty close.
I'm going to go grab that.
Actually, RPO, you should go get it.
Cause you don't have gold armor.
Oh, hey, there's a...
Oh, go ahead.
There's a...
Oh, a planet cracker load?
It sucked.
I hate that one.
Yeah.
There's people on it.
Okay, okay.
Just fuck off it.
Fuck off it.
I'm gonna shoot.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go roof.
I'm still harmonizing.
I cracked one.
He's got gold armor.
I'm harmonizing.
Yeah, he got the gold armor from the thing probably.
Yeah, they're just leaving.
Yeah, I cracked him.
One guy's still on it, yeah.
I'm just gonna move around just in case I don't get shot.
They beat us to it.
Damn.
Let's go there.
Do you want the, uh, the Krayber if there is one, Shafar?
Sure.
Yeah, I'm gonna get a sniper, enjoy.
I love a sniper.
There's a gold armor?
It's SMG and LMG.
There's self-rescue kit.
I'm gonna take this.
And then there's a Tempest, guys.
Tempest is fucking broken, dude.
Does anyone want the emergency?
Does anyone want the self-rescue kit?
I'm dropping a self-rescue kit here if one of you want it.
I don't need it.
There's also a shield here.
Emergency shield.
Who has the TP?
I have the TP.
You want it?
Yeah, yeah.
Slide it to me.
And then just take one of the self-reses.
I have self-rescue ready.
There's another one here.
Do you all have one?
Can I have two?
I think so.
Do you all have a self-res?
I don't need them, so I don't want to pick one up.
Grab it.
Yeah, you should get it.
Yeah, grab it.
There's two on the floor.
It's a gold thing.
You just walked over it.
You can't carry two, by the way.
Yeah, make it run.
Okay, Doki, take this.
She has.
We need an emergency shield.
We got a guy with an emergency shield.
It's still pretty good.
It drops a bubble on the floor.
Another airdrop?
Should I go for this for gold?
Yeah.
Yeah, let's go for it.
We're just going to land.
Can you ping it where it lands?
I pinged it.
It's red ping.
We can look for it.
If there's people on it, we just go back to where we were.
Okay.
There was a team here near it before.
Oh, people are still fighting.
Our spot was kind of broken, though.
We should go back.
Yeah, we'll go back.
You guys should maybe go back.
Okay.
I'm sure for now, we can anchor.
I gotta protect you guys.
Do you not want to anchor?
Two grown men.
We'll be fine.
Yeah.
They don't need a guardian.
I'm giving an overwatch.
There's a Kraber here.
It's a Kraber.
Oh.
Well, do I go back now?
You go take the Kraber.
We go back.
Okay.
Moving around again.
Oh, you want the Kraber, don't you?
There's a car.
Oh.
Are you fighting?
They're fighting.
I'm good.
They're running away.
They're running.
They wanted the Kraber, bro.
Yeah, they wanted the Kraber.
Yeah, they just wanted to zone them off of it.
That's my Kraber.
Yeah, it's his.
They run to the...
Alright.
Let's go.
Alright, I'm waiting in the car.
I hope I don't get shot at.
I'm gonna grab that stock in the shop.
Do you think there's people up there now?
I'm worried that we lost their spot.
I can scan.
Yeah.
We're going back.
Alright.
Well, the Surefour and I die, remember us.
We're not stuck, are we?
Bro.
I think we might be stuck.
We'll do a little left.
A little right.
Left.
Oh, we got the other.
Alright, we got it.
Alright, I wait.
How the fuck did you do that?
Is that range?
I wish I knew.
Alright.
No one's there, so we're safe.
My lipstick locust didn't pick anyone up on CN.
Good lipstick.
Nice.
Looks good on you.
Lipstick brings all the boys to his yard.
Third life.
Better than yours.
I parked my car inside.
I have 500 moolah, dude.
I could buy a bunch of shit.
Oh, yeah.
Is there an upgrade station nearby?
There's one across.
But then we would have to give up our spot.
Yeah, we'd have to give it up.
Is that worth it?
Oh, yeah.
There's still 12.
I'm gonna see if it's open, man.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
We'll anchor this fire cells.
There's people in the house.
Should we stay on the roof or what?
So they know we're here?
The roof is weird.
They...
There's no one here.
I'm crouched in this corner.
They'll never know.
I'm worried to get shot.
Chill, chill.
Hey, what's that?
Just don't get shot.
I'm gonna throw a shark in here.
That's the drop.
Okay, I think we're good.
I hear a car.
I do too.
Yeah, just get your upgrades.
I'll watch you and then I'll upgrade.
Oh, I'm in perfect positioning.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
You're proning?
Sure for it?
Let me get a shotgun.
Eeeeeee.
Oh my gosh.
Everybody is so sweaty.
Nobody has fully died yet.
Alright.
Go, go, go, go.
You're next.
Bro!
We're stuck on the door.
You guys are...
You guys are too thick.
Too thick for the doors.
Someone got right over.
Door stuck.
Wait.
I saw a scan over there.
Can you ping?
I'm trying to.
I saw a scan.
Yeah, there's people in that building.
Alright, we gotta go.
They're fighting in this thing in front of us, Maka.
Yeah, yeah, let's just dip.
I didn't even show up.
I was gonna say, I threw a party from the car like you drive us kinda near.
I didn't even show up on my screen.
Yeah, we could take over each.
Yeah, like from here.
What the fuck did you mark?
If I see one, I just smoke them.
No, they're just sitting in that diner.
Yeah, they're in the building.
They definitely killed someone.
Or attempted to kill someone.
There's people over there.
We're coming.
This car is kinda slow.
Oh, okay.
I see it.
Okay, I see the thing.
Okay, wait.
We should play a different spot, no?
Like maybe here?
We can play like high to low from here, I think.
Right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Isn't our walk-in kind of...
I need to adjust the line.
We should probably...
Instead of keeping these cars, we should keep the flying cars so we can fly over the ravine.
We can use both.
This car is really strong.
The armor is really really strong.
But this one can fly over, can it?
No, it can't.
But I mean, I can just glide if it comes to it.
Yeah.
So yeah, there's no way to fly...
No way to fly...
This is concerning, that hill order.
Oh, hey!
One spot's dead!
We're not last.
Not give me...
Zva ult.
Where?
Double Zva ult.
Give me ult.
It's interesting.
I can't, bro.
I'm programmed like that.
Yes, Vielen Unders.
You made me seen on the ref.
Can I, like, pop some shots?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think we can't do anything about it...
It's one outside.
Sure, yeah.
Crack them.
we're not chilling like here.
We're gonna chill in here.
Knocked!
Knock, knock, knock, knock, knock.
Nice!
Knock!
Wait, do we help?
We're not pushing.
We're not pushing...
We're gonna push those two teams.
Yeah...
We're helping for all...
Just make sure no one walks in behind us on our North.
Yeah...
I'm staying prone down this building.
North?
Where's North?
He's prone to building.
North is at the top of your map.
I was looking at my compass and I was turning around to make sure I know where North is.
North is straight up.
That's true.
Glad you know where your compass is at the very least.
Yeah, I know my cardinal direction.
Let's meet up there.
I'm proud.
I'm doing it, guys.
That's better something.
On the roof, on the roof.
All right, zero.
Eh.
I'm walking.
I'm beaming these guys.
Zero damage?
I'm doing it?
Oh, these guys are outside the zone?
Yeah, yeah.
We should probably ...
Can you keep that?
They might come to us though.
Because our ridge is in here.
Wait, there's a car right here.
There's a car, ...
Yo, Mac.
I think they're gonna come to us here.
Wait, there's a car that's just driving.
You guys hold that side?
We'll hold this side.
We'll try.
They're definitely gonna come to us because they can't...
Uh, they might go for these houses though.
I'm holding.
Oh, I'm holding.
They're not.
It seems like they're all in here soon.
Yeah, but they don't...
We've got any edges on here.
He's not.
That's true.
Look at the roof.
They might fly.
You're shooting at me, bro.
I don't think the people... You guys are even shooting at a rendering for me.
They're here.
Turn up your view distance.
I think it's at max.
PC gap, I guess.
I don't know.
Maybe you're right here.
Oh, he just got gunned.
View range extreme.
Yeah, you didn't have your view range up.
I didn't max your rendering.
I still can't see them.
They might just be at us at a render distance.
I mean, Doki can anchor there with their TP.
And then you can come up to us if you want.
Unless I get fucked up.
Maybe we shouldn't use our TP now when we gotta move.
Yeah, we have to move, though.
The zone's pushing us.
We're not gonna TP.
If she gets pushed, she can TP us back.
Wait, wait.
The zone is pushing in.
What do we do?
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna get out.
Get out of the fucking car.
Bro, you're not letting me get in, dude.
Thank you.
He's bullying me, dude.
We should get his hill.
Get his hill.
Yeah, we're gonna go here.
This hill here is in.
Hello.
There's a car behind you.
You should grab that one.
We just hold this ridge and make sure no one walks into us.
You want me to drive?
Look here, look here.
The car is the better.
Roger.
I don't have a lot of experience driving.
Just drive in there and then get out.
They're in the zone.
They're gonna race in the zone.
What if I die?
There's two teams.
Keep in mind.
I don't think the team died.
Someone else drive?
I'm gonna move the car for her.
No, you got it.
You're getting ganked from somewhere else.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna drive up and play kind of psycho.
Okay.
There's a team here.
On the right.
Scraper these guys.
I see him.
On the right?
Yeah, on the right.
Crack one.
He smoked it though.
Team on the left might be racing in zone.
Where were they?
I don't know.
Yeah, they are.
It doesn't hurt that bad yet.
It's gonna hurt bad on that.
I'm looking at my left.
Oh yeah, one's knocked.
One's knocked.
I'm trying to find.
I find, I think.
I knocked.
Yeah, I find him.
I'm looking at my left.
I don't see anyone.
This space over here by me, we can't give up.
Okay?
This space here.
Okay, if you want to anchor that.
Which space?
Guys, have a knock over here.
We can do racing.
Okay.
I'll look at that side.
Where's the knock?
It's right behind us.
Over there.
I knocked the guy here on the left.
Mac.
Outside here.
Wait, there's a floaty car behind us.
Floaty car behind us.
Wait, ping.
Oh, I see.
I see.
These pins are so slow.
These guys are coming in the car.
It's me.
There is an actual car.
Look at the car.
Wait, I'm so confused.
Bro, your name didn't render, bro.
Wait on the map.
It rendered for me.
You're shooting me.
I'm fucking demons again.
Oh, these are full killed.
These are full killed.
This guy ulted.
Ulted on the right.
Yeah.
I want to loot this guy.
I'm out of ammo.
Where do you want me to look at?
I'm anchoring the spot over here.
There's a car here.
I'm getting the other car.
I'm coming over.
I cracked the guy in the car.
Armored car.
I think RPI and UCF at 59 so we can get the rest.
We can save.
Dude, his name didn't render.
There's people over here too.
Yo, cover me.
Cover me.
Yo, can you heal me?
They got some poison on me or some shit.
Yeah, I can.
I'm heading over.
They're shooting corrosive rounds.
I'm going to pick him up.
I got you.
Wait.
I'm using my...
Put it down.
It's okay.
I have my own shield.
I'm good.
Okay, okay.
I'm waiting.
They're trying to push.
Ready?
Cover.
Just in case.
I knocked one over there.
We need some better...
We gotta kill our right, dude, I'm scared over here.
I'm looking this way, just in case.
No call, no call, no call.
Wait, there's people fighting.
I'm scanning for you, Averillo.
Keep punching right, I'm playing with Mac.
I'm anchoring here, I'm anchoring here.
Track this guy, I'm pushing up.
I'm looking right side for us.
Track him, track him, Mac.
Drunk, drunk, drunk.
Someone call me, mate, or something.
Under tree, under tree!
Under tree, hello!
Hold on, hold on.
There's more, more, more.
You guys got this.
I'm just keeping our hill.
Yeah, me too.
I'm anchoring.
They're putting walls down.
I just don't, I don't have portal.
If you do die, I don't have portal.
I'm moving into center.
I crack one, I crack one, Mac in this bush.
There's a team right here.
I'm trying to get knaves.
Wait, behind us, behind us!
Wait, oh!
They landed on very good.
Way to kill us, way to kill us on me.
Way to kill us on me.
I got landed on.
I'm done, I'm done, I'm done.
Yeah, I'm down too.
I didn't even hear it.
We might be able to res here, Shurfar.
Let me go down.
I didn't even hear them land on us.
Dude, go down more.
Dude.
Can you watch back above us?
No.
What the fuck am I watching?
You are crazy.
I didn't hold on.
You can play behind the wall here.
I'm gonna TP and Mac.
He's not spam.
I'm trying to get these guys killed.
I'm getting fucking cards.
I killed one.
Oh my god.
I got ran over.
We got ran over.
We abandoned our cars.
We put up stuffers.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
They're fucked up on my side of zone, walking in here.
If you play stuffers, you can kill them.
I...
Dude, he's trying to finish me.
Bro, you hit him.
Just hide your butt.
You hit the shirt.
I'm getting cursed.
No.
You hit top four.
It's fine.
Dude, we both got ran over.
Bro, I got...
Aw.
I got landed on.
I was just about to TP and Mac and didn't get ran over there.
I'm so sad.
I pushed into zone with the car and then Doki got killed.
And then I had to res RPR.
Wait, I didn't realize you left.
We got a bunch of kills though, didn't we?
Like six kills?
Yeah, you guys did.
We got a couple.
You got six.
I got three.
I didn't even hear them.
I got none.
There's like no sound when they land on you.
Oh, it's because they used the thing that Nobear is using right now.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
They used that and repositioned the knee because they thought that was by myself.
Oh.
I feel like if I TPed on you, Mac, earlier, we would have probably wiped out everything on the left there.
Probably, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, top four is pretty good.
I should have probably just TPed and we just wiped the whole thing.
I did 469 damage and not the one.
Yeah, you can TP from like 200 meters away, by the way.
Yeah, it's...
Oh, that's crazy.
I was thinking you'll just wipe that alone and then I'll play in the back.
But then Doki got insta-kill.
I feel like when Doki got insta-kill, I should just keep it on you instantly.
23 damage.
Let's go.
Still, I mean, you had most kills on the arm.
So, we were doing something, right?
Made it?
Wait, we're...
Did it?
Yeah, you had an MP, didn't you?
Yeah, he had MVP.
I had three kills.
I think that's just for our team.
I don't think that's like...
I just for our team.
Oh, that's...
Yeah, that's just our team.
Yeah, so we have six kills in gen- we have six kills in total.
How should I express happiness?
Did I get knocked out of the lobby?
They're gonna remake the lobby.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, I was like, where's the lobby?
Get my food real quick.
We are back.
I'm gonna grab my phone charger.
He's about to be slow.
He's coming back with a full belly.
Nice.
It's not hitting anything, then.
Yeah, it's done.
It's over.
Oh, I hear this.
Might as well go to bed, then.
I feel like if they're gonna do that, I feel like we might as well just not anchor.
How do they fly on you?
I don't even know that.
You have the flying...
There's a girl that does the flying ability, and it's like a redeploy.
Yeah.
It's Valk, yeah.
I didn't hear that at all.
You can't hear it.
It doesn't have audio.
You just have to like watch for it.
You have to like constantly be looking up and shit.
Oh, so it's like...
You can't leave me alone.
So you constantly look up all the time, like...
The thing is, I didn't look behind us, but I can't look up because of that.
And then, I think like when Surefour left, like they saw me by myself and just landed on me.
Yeah, I mean, you're smart from them.
Yeah.
That character is great.
Maybe we should play that character.
She's good.
She just loses a ton of value late game.
Like for like fighting, she's pretty useless.
It takes a lot of time to put the ult, right?
Yeah.
So basically, it's a circle that she puts down and then you step in the circle and press space and you like just go flying.
Oh.
It's like double the height of a Valko.
It's really high up, how high it sends you.
But like, it's not that hard to shoot people out of it.
Like it looks hard, but it's really easy to shoot people out of the air.
Alright, so it's a different lobby, right?
Yeah, we're just waiting for the car.
Yeah, I wish I could see you get run over.
Yeah, we both got run over.
What's funny is he got run over and the same car run me over like a millisecond.
Doing, doing.
Wait, where was your car?
I thought you had a car, Shurfur.
What happened?
Oh, I had to drop it down.
They took it down.
To pick up RPR?
Pretty sure they took our car and ran us over their own car.
I think so.
Wait, are you sure?
Because I think they took one of our armor cars when they landed on me.
Nah.
That's fucked up.
That's really fucked up.
The skills humans are born with seem more challenging.
Yeah.
Can't believe we just do that.
Maybe we should always move as four.
I think so too.
I think it's because the TTK is so fast.
Or we should always look up, man.
I think at endgame, we should look up.
Like, someone has to be...
On endgame, someone has to look up.
Just in case.
You just have to pay attention to who has to move around you.
Because you'll see them ulting.
Like, it's a really big fucking, like, indicator.
Really?
If you just know who to watch.
Yeah, it's a huge, like, very, very visible indicator.
Okay, maybe you should be the one to look then.
I can't.
My character, I can't do that.
I have to play like a psycho.
Because I'm the only one who can frontline.
Everyone just remember to look up every few seconds.
Just, like, give a look.
Just always look up.
If you're anchoring, like, all you gotta do is look behind and look up.
But what if I wanna...
No, just pay attention to who has to move.
You'll see it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I should've said the team across wasn't in.
It was definitely the team across that just, like, Val culted on you.
Oh, I see.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Val culted to go across the map because they didn't have a floaty car.
And I moved up to get into...
Every single part of me is replaced.
Wait, you didn't...
Oh, my gosh.
If...
Why didn't you wait for me to get in the car?
I should've just pushed to the map.
You were out of course.
When Mac crossed, I should've just ulted on him instantly.
And then we just wiped the entire left side there.
So then even if you guys died, we still...
Yeah, they were resetting on the left too.
Yeah.
But, like, as I was about to, like, commit to, like, go try and kill them, I got...
I started getting shot in the back by the guys that were shooting you.
So I had to, like, pause and throw smokes and heal and let them reset.
Uh...
You had two cars, actually.
Where's the lobby?
Waiting.
Oh, yeah.
Where did our lobby go?
Waitings, waitings.
How may I assist?
Alright.
Sorry.
I forgot to...
Mute my...
To do the...
Sorry, my mind's fried.
I don't even know how to kill.
I don't even get a lot of points.
I forgot to do the hotkey for mute.
So I have to tab out every time to mute, guys.
Yeah.
This is fake trigger.
I see...
From, like, the first set, teams are dropping, like, 30 possible games.
And I don't think...
You wish this the game right now.
Or watch the stream to get keys.
Or they're just killing hell of people, but...
I don't think that was possible.
There was a scoring system somewhere, wasn't there?
Are you enjoying yourself?
I'm having fun.
This is a fun team.
We get 17 points.
It's very tryhard, though.
I think...
Apparently, our team's the only team that's sponsored to be.
So we should get 23 points for the game.
So, like, the rest of the teams here...
First place gets 25 points, better.
...signed up.
So they're, like, extra tryhard.
So it's heavily placement, basically.
And then we're, like...
We're, like...
We're chill, but also try...
Tryhard.
Yeah.
But, um...
But, yeah.
This is a very, very sweaty lobby.
Apparently...
Yeah, um...
Bro, I'm not kidding.
No name.
No nothing.
Dude, he didn't just try and gun you down.
We told him...
Bro, I destroyed you.
...that that's your teammate.
And he still kept...
Yeah, yeah.
That's true.
That's me.
Nah, nah.
I cannot hear you guys.
I was locked in.
I wonder why he was out of ammo.
No.
Yeah, but I looted the box and I was full ammo again.
What do you mean about...
Hmm.
Okay, but, like...
I'm ironically, like...
I was locked in.
I thought that guy was about to run me over.
No name.
No nothing.
I'm shooting, dude.
Like, what do you want from me?
I'm locked in.
Like, a mile away.
It's a bug, probably, or something.
I don't know.
Listen, man.
I was just locked in.
Will I still be Camille?
I was just locked in, dude.
Maybe it's because I was ADS.
He couldn't see the name.
But he was just missing everything.
So, I'm saying is if Mac was an enemy, he's dead like three times there, dude.
I'm locked.
Sure, he was.
I'm not letting anyone go up to us.
I wonder...
Wait, is there friendly fire on your team's car?
Yeah.
Yeah, he fucked my car up.
Wait, you fucked my car up.
You fucked me up, bro.
Fuck that shit up.
I was locked in, dude.
Blew my windshields out.
Maybe that's why we lost.
Yeah, okay.
That's why we lost.
Not because you got landed on by four people.
Yeah, and who left me alone!
Nobody told me to get over to you guys.
Because that wasn't the plan.
Well, that was a bad plan, leaving me to anchor.
Oh, Mac made it.
Yell at him, not me.
It's my bad, I trust the turkey.
What?
Oh, he just made a 1v4, an entire team, as the non-mobile character.
I believe it.
As no TV whatsoever, other than for you guys to TV to me.
He's like, let's split up, gang!
Thought you were built like that.
How long do we have to wait for next lobby?
What's going on?
I have no idea.
What's the word?
Getting all the points and stuff.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, I said getting the scores up.
But I have to manually score it.
Yeah, you have to count everything.
Oh, apparently the...
Can I pee?
I think we're on... Wait, what's your ping for that server?
You don't see it.
It just says latency.
It doesn't say like...
It just says the word latency.
I'm just wondering if it's East Coast or West Coast.
Because the Korean team was saying how it was difficult to play.
Maybe I can't see ping.
Maybe it's like you enable it somewhere.
Let me see.
A network monitoring display.
Okay, I guess this stuff.
I'll see you next game.
But it wasn't bad.
I mean, it was laggy obviously, but it wasn't like...
Yeah.
Horrible for me.
Oh my god, I just queued a game.
Sorry, just leave the game.
It's quick play.
No, no, no, it like cancelled.
Oh, they made the lobby.
Okay, I'll hide my screen this time so I don't leak the fucking password.
Yeah, I'll be great then.
The only single part of me is...
I... No.
I don't think so.
I think that's why the three make the lobby.
Because somebody...
Not us, of course.
I'm going to pee.
Nah.
Not us.
They're back.
Someone did the thing.
Who could it be?
RPR.
You're right.
It's RPR's fault.
100%.
Yeah.
Just like how he let me die there.
But even if it's RPR's fault, I'm still going to blame Doki.
Wait, what?
What did I do?
I'm literally the support.
Someone's not getting healed today.
So...
I'll take the heals, don't worry.
Yeah, never blame the support.
I can hold people hostage.
A TP and the heals.
That's right.
I saved lives.
I wonder what points do we get.
23.
In total?
Yeah, that game should be 23.
17 from placement, we had 6 kills.
Whoa!
That could hit us at top 5.
Well, we'll never know.
Chat, what placement are we at?
At chat.
This is your time to shine.
No Elp.
Guys, I just want to know what placements we got.
What you crunching on?
Yeah, what you eating?
What did you get for lunch?
Or dinner?
Oh, wait.
That sounds good.
Mm-hmm.
You're going to get EP?
No.
You're going to get EP while on a full stomach?
I don't get food comas.
Man.
You probably don't eat too much.
No, I'm fat.
I do eat a lot.
What the fuck?
The food com only happens when you eat a ton.
Remember when he said he's built...
He's the perfect being, remember?
I forgot about that one.
I'm the perfect human.
Yeah, he's the perfect human.
He's literally built different.
I got a big belly.
Thank you so much for slapping it for us.
I really knew that.
I wouldn't have been able to tell how big of a belly it was.
Jesus Christ, man.
He's trying...
He's proving his point.
I got a fat ass too.
Yeah, slap it.
Do some jumping jacks.
Stap against TOS.
How would they know?
Your cab's not up.
They don't know.
It's the...
What's the word?
You said it?
Yeah.
Now it's like...
They know.
Implied.
Implied?
Just slap your ass and say it's your belly.
You can't even English.
Slap your ass and say it's just your belly.
I know English had a second language level.
What's your first language level?
English.
Yes, yes.
I thought he was going to say French.
If he was French Canadian, don't be GG.
I don't think he's...
Yeah, I don't think he's French.
I don't know, bro.
French Canadians?
I'm from the Texas of Canada.
Wait.
Alberta.
Yeah, I was going to say it was Alberta.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
We got oil.
Yeah.
Shit's valid, dude.
Dash, Texas, Canada for you.
You gotta oil.
What are we waiting for?
We're waiting for one person.
Can this one person hurry the fuck up?
Yeah.
Add person.
Where are you?
Chat, what placements are we?
Anyone figure it out?
No one figured it out.
They posted it.
We're third right now.
Oh, we're third?
Ooh!
First is effects team, 36 points.
Second team, 34.
Whoa!
And then us with 23.
Hey, that's pretty...
So wait, effects team won with three kills.
Placements.
They're 36.
Placements 25.
They won with 11.
Oh, 8 kills.
No, wait.
Hold on.
11 kills?
Holy shit, that's a lot of kills.
Wait.
Does it count if you...
Does it count if you kill...
Like, if they respawn and then you kill them again?
Does that count as an extra kill?
Yeah.
Oh, they might have just been respawn farming then.
Oh, that's a strat.
I saw people doing that in the first group A tournament.
They were literally respawn farming.
That's fucking toxic.
You're in a custom lobby tournament getting respawn farming.
Yeah.
Yeah, I saw...
I literally was like watching...
I think it was...
I think it was Frex's team.
Yeah, it was Frex's team.
And like, they killed a weaker team and they were just patrolling the respawns.
And trying to find them.
I was like...
Damn, that's fucked up.
I thought you meant they were running up crafting with the fucking...
Yeah, like they were like...
The gem thing.
I think the team were like...
Was like Genshin players.
I was like...
Damn, that's fucked up.
Oh, man.
I was like...
How much would it be for your team to do that?
Start gifting subs.
Let's get going.
Gifts subs and we'll also respawn farm.
Yeah, Shepard does it for the pleasure of it.
Yeah, but you're just an asshole, dude.
I'll do it for free.
Do we have Genshin players in this hobby or are there?
Tell us which was the Genshin team.
We'll run at them.
Come on, chat.
Wrap them up to us.
Any Genshin...
Wait, hold on, hold on.
Any Genshin players in here?
Nah, I can't write them.
They don't have to be too bad at them.
Yeah.
They've got the lobby chat.
Just like, kitchen players?
Where you guys landed?
Where you landed?
Yeah.
We just wanted to know, you know, we're here to stay far away from you guys.
He's trying to stay away because you guys are like veterans in the gacha space.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
And we just wanted you to...
So we're just trying to make sure you'll stay alive a little longer.
Nothing else.
We'll be your personal bodyguards.
If you see our cards.
Yeah.
If you see our cards, don't shoot.
We just hear the...
We're protecting you.
Yeah.
We're just here to protect you.
Oh my God.
Some of my chat was like, oh, just say anyone hit any sick pulls recently?
I did get a sick pull yesterday.
Oh yeah.
What did you get?
What's her name?
I'm looking into this.
What game?
I got Lilium in a 20 pull.
What game is that?
Ethereo restart.
The fuck?
I was going to say, the fuck is that?
He's playing the indie gachas.
Yeah.
He is deep.
It's new.
It's Epic Seven.
Wait, how much did you spend?
I don't know.
That 20 pull was free pulls.
Oh.
Maybe it could be set pulls though.
Well, to pity it, you need 180.
No, but there's like some games where if you get free pulls, it's just like set pulls.
Uh-huh.
Huh.
Like...
Wait, did you just start and got the free 20?
Or...
Or was it like you built it up?
Well, because like the...
The horse game is...
It just started.
The horse game gives you like a default pull.
Like it's a set pull.
What?
Um...
Like when you do a free pull.
Are you talking about pity?
Yeah, the gotcha game.
The horse game.
Are you talking about pity?
No, I'm not.
I'm talking about like when you play...
When they do the tutorial thing.
You're like, here's like some free rolls for you.
And then it gives you like a...
Uh...
Like a set pull.
I've been playing this game for like three months.
Oh!
What?
I said it.
Did you just play it?
As in like...
Just started.
Yeah, yesterday.
I don't remember this.
I'm being gaslit I think.
Why are we not starting?
Everybody's here.
Sitting.
Waiting.
Where are they?
Did you start game?
Did they swap players?
Wait, where?
They might have shuffled some teams.
Team 10?
Wait, did they shuffle teams because people were too...
Too try hard?
I think one person couldn't like connect or something.
Oh, I was gonna say.
Like what?
How did they...
What do you mean they swap players?
I know like the confirmed teams are different.
Than like what's on the list.
My bedtime soon.
Alright?
Let's get going.
It's a Saturday.
You have bedtime on a Saturday?
No, like Asia.
Cause it's like...
What?
Oh wait, no.
It's 8 a.m.
right now in Japan.
Yeah, it's 8 a.m.
Or EU.
Should be morning.
Wait, no.
It's EU.
EU bedtime.
Yeah.
It's 1 a.m.
from Europe.
Yeah.
I mean, max bedtime is like...
That's not bedtime.
It's like 6.
Yeah, max bedtime is like 10 or 11 p.m.
He's an old man.
No.
That's not what I told.
I told her that I'd be on till 1 or 2.
No, no.
You said you go to bed at 10 or 11.
And I cooked my schedule now.
Well, you cooked my schedule.
I cooked your schedule?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm helping you get paid.
I got a sponsor opportunity.
I won't hit you up.
I won't hit you up the next time I got a sponsor opportunity.
No, no, no.
Stop being too hasty.
Boss?
3, 2, 1.
Yeah, I was good for like 2 weeks.
I was like, man, this is a great schedule.
Someone left.
Again?
Yesterday I woke up at 6.
Maybe if you spam chat you get ticked.
Server number 1.
Oh, should we start things?
Wait, we have the number 1 Camille player in the server?
Taxi's not here.
There's a tag that's like number 1 Camille player.
Yay.
I'm a rare breed to Europe.
How are you rare?
You know, one time in my chat, one guy came in and he asked me what breed of Europe.
I was.
Oh yeah.
I remember.
I fucking banned his ass.
What do you mean?
I'm a fucking dog, dude.
You didn't even answer him?
No.
Fucker.
He doesn't deserve to know.
I don't know.
You did crouch in front of me when you wanted those dollars.
Oh, true.
It's the classic...
Bro, whatever, bro.
I'm not even going to justify that.
Bark, bark.
You know what?
I know.
Didn't you have a toggle where you were a dog man?
Who?
You.
Okay.
Huh?
What are you talking about?
Now he's lying.
Let's go.
Agriculture.
I want to farm.
I gave it to Mac.
We're gonna go on this TP.
Oh.
And where's that?
Yeah.
Where does it go?
I was like, where does it go?
Yeah.
We're just going to go to the observatory again.
Okay.
All the small things.
I think there's a team in this TP though, but I think it should be okay.
Are you sure?
I'm not really sure.
I've never taken this before.
Are you sure?
SPANG!
Wait, we're going to observatory?
Yeah, we're on this one.
I'm detaching because my guy looks weird flying leave with you.
Oh my god, you are lagging on my screen.
Yeah, I have to fly alone because it just looks weird.
The other team is going over here on my red bike.
I went the wrong way.
Oh, I'm fine.
Okay.
It should be fine.
Yeah, you'll be fine.
If you don't die, then you're alive.
And if you die, you're dead.
I have another respawn if we die.
I mean, I'm just spitting right now.
Type shit.
Type's the S word.
Nice.
I literally just teleported.
Oh my gosh, this house had like three different armors.
Bloodyator.
That I didn't pick up, apparently.
I pinged the blue here.
Blue armor.
I'll take that.
I think the ping should be a bit bigger, though.
100%.
It's so hard to see where you guys are pinging stuff.
That's because you're blind.
No, I'm not.
I mean, I do wear glasses, but no, I'm not.
Shit.
Leaked?
Doxxed?
How?
What do you mean to you here?
How the fuck?
How?
That's just how the fuck then.
I need it.
Blue back right here.
Oh, no.
I need better guns.
Guys, I need something that's not white armor.
W moment.
There's another blue armor here for you guys.
I haven't seen a guardian yet.
I need a scoping tin.
I need like a... There's another blue armor.
There's a beast pasta.
There's a 2x.
I've got a 2x for you.
There's so many blue armors, guys.
I need a scope from a gladiator.
I'm looking for a Cantio, sir, gladiator.
I don't have either.
I have a red dot right now, but I would like any scope.
Yo, here's blue armor.
I pinged like four blue armors.
I want, I want, I want.
Reloading.
Where'd you ping the 3x?
Blue armor here.
Fire?
On my balcony over here.
I'm in the MAC right now.
I'm gonna go to this house.
Oh, okay.
There's a, there's a armor car in front of us here.
Like, uh, that we can use.
Not that there's anybody there.
Uh, big.
I'm kind of used.
You're used?
Used.
Man, used.
Like Swedish for juiced.
Whatever you do in your free time is up to you.
Yeah, we won't judge.
You guys have your mind is in the gutter dude.
This is self-report.
You literally said, you're used.
Self-report, self-report.
I said I'm used.
Yeah, you're used.
Yeah, you said that again.
Yeah, you said it again.
That means juiced in Swedish.
You're used.
I think this guy's lying.
Yeah, I think he's, I think he's gaslighting us.
Swedish English, you guys need to...
God, American kids eat hot cheetos and wine.
Yeah, all they do is lie.
We don't even have hot cheetos here, man.
That's American shit.
That's why you're lying all the time.
All they do is lie and slur.
I'm about to leave you guys behind.
That would be the first time.
Oh, typical URP is leaving us.
Yeah, we just go back up.
Beep, beep, I'm going to source energy labs.
I've been abandoned.
Wait, I'm gonna be abandoned too.
I've been punished for the sins of my teammates.
Wait, no, RP are abandoned all of us.
Do I have to pick you guys up for real?
No, I got sure for sure for it.
Pick me up.
That's okay, sure for it.
Bro, you used me.
You almost dragged past me.
I was trying to just push you.
You want this car?
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
Yeah.
There could be someone here because of the...
I just noticed this is TP route.
Yeah.
Let's respawn farm them.
I'm so fucking down.
Okay, but what if they're good though?
Let's respawn farm them.
We're better.
Okay, okay.
I believe.
I'm believing less because Shurford is trying the front line.
Yeah, Shurford was really sure about it.
We're better.
There.
Deadly and beautiful.
Yo dude look.
My house, my house.
The only sick mortgage.
The sick hasn't revealed anything.
The stores open.
Oh.
Up here I climbed my earth.
Yeah, yeah, I fucking... I... I car bounced off your car, that shit was a loot.
Wait, why are we here again?
Looting.
Oh.
And armor and stuff.
Did anyone find a DMR Cantius?
Three times.
And you Cantius.
Three times, three times, three times zooming scope.
No Cantius around me.
Time to put our plans in.
I'm dropping a purple mag for Cantius here.
I dropped it three times.
I'll take that.
I don't have any smokes, man.
I need mollies.
Molly.
Open up the sky.
Oh, purple back back here.
Has anyone found a extra Cantius?
Cantius, Cantius here.
No.
Where?
I pinged it on the bottom of the... facility.
Oh.
We have it down here.
Yay!
There's a Cantius right here.
I don't have any... I don't have any big medkits.
Ooh, gold hammer.
Wait, there's a bottom?
There's a sniper extended mag.
And a...
Where the fuck is... Oh, there it is.
What?
That.
Yeah.
The bottom has all the good bullshit.
I'm collecting money.
Yeah, the bottom has all the good shit.
Yeah, and the roof as well is good shit.
Weee.
Look, look.
The roof has gold armor.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of good shit right there.
Yeah, good stuff for Balvin, good stuff for Balvin.
And there's gas.
I got gas in case we run out of it.
I need to... have I seriously not seen any smoke nades?
What?
I don't think I have.
Nope.
I'm gonna go for upgrades.
I found random regular grenades.
Have fun.
Zone's coming, by the way.
Oh, I found smoke grenades.
YOOOP!
Where's the car?
Shut the fuck up.
Let's go for upgrades.
Ah, it hurts, it hurts.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Guys, you gotta go left for upgrades.
Wait, where did you leave the car?
Okay.
I don't know.
I just looked for the car on the map.
Yeah, just car items.
Yeah.
Upgrade time.
Wait, I don't have enough upgrades.
Actually, do I?
I only have 50.
Do you have money?
Wait, actually, I think I do have 50.
I do.
I got horrible upgrades.
I'm gonna get the, I have, I'm gonna get the helmet.
I got a skull piercer.
I out regen the zone with the perk that I got.
What the?
Oh, I got the quick, ah, quick ult's fine.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Beep, beep.
Everyone leave me?
Yeah.
Ya.
Hmm.
Not everyone.
Ya, Max it real wood.
There's no buddies, we're a buddies.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
To the left.
Yeah.
Great.
That's been pinged on the map.
That's my ping.
So then follow it.
So why don't you give sure for credit?
I don't know about that.
If you look at the map, I'm yellow.
Are you?
How do you know that?
He's not lying.
At the bottom left, we have our colors.
I'm green, green, green.
Light blue.
You are red and I am yellow.
Or maybe you're colorblind.
Me say a long ramp.
Alright, where are we going, boys?
Probably Harmonizers again, but they're really far, so someone's probably on them by now.
Wait, someone left a car here.
No, it's just a random car.
Yeah?
There's one in front of the other teleporter as well.
Alright dude, where is it?
Where's that car?
At the other teleporter.
There was no car there.
There was.
No, there wasn't.
There's another one of these cars.
Oh, I see it.
They're just dumb and dumb.
Yeah.
You know, it's smart, I don't.
No, yes.
What?
Wait, which one is it?
Who's who?
This was used, wasn't it?
I thought we're on a bunny system.
I'll leave that up to interpretation.
I thought we're on a bunny system, sure boy.
You can have dumb buddies.
Yeah,
it's smart, smart, smart and dumb order.
Yeah, I can have dumb buddies.
Smart and smart and smart and dumb order.
Good combo.
I think someone's on that harmonizer.
There's three of them.
They're all on.
Three of them are yellow.
You want to fight them?
One of those is a care pack beam.
Oh, yeah, I knew that.
I think I know who the dumb one is.
Dumb ass.
Saiba.
Let's try and fight them, but they're kind of in the middle of zone.
Let's fight them.
Oh, they shoot back.
Fuck, GTA.
Shoot the tires out.
They're going behind you.
There's one behind you.
I'm shooting.
Reload, reload.
Oh, you might need to...
Whoa!
I can't shoot because you activated the armor.
Yeah.
Oh!
Get this guy in the blue car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In the Harry Potter car.
Yeah, focus his car.
Get back in, Doki.
Oh, my God.
Where is armor going down?
I'm putting it down now.
You guys...
My stop is to zoom.
Drive by.
I stopped them.
Nice.
Oh, that's you.
Oh, my God.
What's going on?
In the close building.
Yeah, yeah.
We got him on scan.
I'm healing.
I'm going with Shurfer.
Yeah, go kill him.
Wait, this hurts.
This hurts.
I got puddled.
Ah, ah, ah.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
I can't do anything.
I don't know where he is.
He's up there.
He's on the roof.
Hold on.
He's throwing a bunch of shit at us.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
All my bolts missed.
It's Aiden the destroyer.
Oh, it's them.
Take TP.
Yeah.
I got TP at the bottom.
I'm just burning, dude.
Hold on.
I don't have heals.
Look down and press it.
I'm dying through the fucking...
Oh, my God.
I died through the window.
Outside, outside.
He's one.
He's one inside.
I got him.
Oh, fuck.
Another window here.
Just play your life map.
I mean, we have respawned.
Do we?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, we did.
We never...
We only...
Give me knock?
What the fuck?
I'm giving you knock.
I'm knocking you.
I'm getting...
I'm body blocking.
I can maybe get the reset here.
You're getting stabbed through the window, but they're missing.
Wait.
Is that a different team?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm gonna use my wall as soon as you res me.
I'm resing?
I already used my heal, by the way.
I had to heal myself.
Stop crawling.
Oh.
Stop crawling!
I heard you say I'm gonna...
I heard you say I'm gonna make space, so I went to walk to them.
I can't see anything.
I'm inside of you guys.
I can't tell.
Are you inside of me?
I'm trying to find him.
He's inside of you?
How does it feel?
How does it...
I'm sneaking us when we res.
It's rough over here.
It's rough.
I'm so confused.
Okay.
You guys see everyone on the map.
Good job.
I don't know what's happening.
I don't know.
There's one inside.
In the smoke.
Really?
They are right there, right there.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, over here!
I'm re-sing!
I'm re-sing yet again.
You guys are fine.
I don't have heals.
Oh no!
On top, there's a window!
I'm healing.
There's a team on the window.
I'll fight the other side.
There's another team.
There's more outside.
Can you res him?
I got a reload.
I didn't reload just last night.
Guys, I didn't do anything.
I was just res bot.
I was res bot.
I died twice.
Me and RPR did the thing.
I resed RPR and I resed him.
I made smokes in a can.
The scan was good, actually.
I know it was a good scan.
Everything else was a little bit tragic.
I would've killed Aiden.
I would've killed Aiden, but my first shot hit the fucking wall because it's the third person.
I don't know why they didn't push.
Someone's getting shot?
Question mark?
I think they died in their bag, that's why.
What's going on anymore?
Like...
I'm scanning?
There's no one on scan who's fighting demons?
It was far.
No, they were far.
We won against the demons, guys.
We won.
Okay, I'm here.
Dude, the shotgun went crazy angle online.
Oh, yeah.
The auto shotgun fucks.
The shotgun did not go crazy for me.
Bro, you were on the ground.
Just like, you can fucking use the camera.
You should see what happened when I tried to shoot him on the roof.
Dude, we live.
That was some Mad Max shit right there.
What the car chase into the fucking...
The Harry Potter car, I'm fucking him up.
I hit 42 on it.
Can you not steal... 700?
Can you not steal other people's things?
Yeah, you can.
What do you mean?
Well, it said there was a shotgun with Skullpiercer and I picked it up and now I don't have a Skullpiercer.
I saw it.
You don't have it on your gun?
No, I saw it.
No.
I did.
Oh, that's where it went.
Someone yoinked it.
Yeah, someone took it.
Well, I was looting it?
No, I had a high X ammo thing.
My explosive changes your gun, by the way.
It changes like what it does.
It's weird.
Oh, okay.
Can I take it off?
No.
I only have two smokes, bro.
It depends on what gun you have it on.
It's on the Gladiator.
It might be good.
I don't know.
I haven't used it on that.
But on the DMR, it literally turns the DMR into a shit gun.
I mean, this was from the Aiden's team, right?
So it should be good.
I can't move these guys in the body blocking.
Yeah, my bad.
Can't back?
Can't grab that.
That's like literally next to us.
Let's just give it to us.
Yeah, we have five cars outside our fucking building.
Grab one of the whips.
All right, Trevor.
Buddy system.
Yeah, you got your own car.
Okay, I guess.
No one's on it.
It's good to have your own car.
I believe in you.
I don't wanna... No, my car has no wheel!
You guys shot this car's wheel off!
There was like 17 million cars there.
I'm running back.
Uh-uh.
My car has no wheel.
Why didn't you just grab your car?
Dude, other car was...
No, I'm talking about RPR.
This guy drives over the car.
He was in a bad spot.
Res me!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm making a portal.
I'm inside the building.
I killed one.
We knocked one.
Okay, I'm teleporting you.
Yeah, teleport.
I'm scanning.
I think these guys are killable.
Yeah, we killed them after I get resed.
After resed.
And then I have no heals because I used that on Mac.
I'm not gonna play up the left.
I have no, I have no, I have no.
I am not.
I got knocked again through the window.
Hold on, hold on.
Yeah, there is a.
Rest me here.
I'm resing.
It's found at PS.
Oh my god.
You can res, you can.
You can use TP.
Oh, you couldn't.
It's gone.
It's just gone.
Oh, he got full kill.
I could put an ult on his body.
Can I ult on your body?
They are on it, just be careful.
Okay, so that car has no wheel.
They are driving away.
They are driving away, you can get me.
Yeah, just get me.
They are left.
What, fair play?
In this day and age?
I am going to ult on his banner.
You shouldn't need to.
Just put a Q down.
My body is against the garage.
Oh, they are shooting someone else now.
Hold on, let me Q.
Oh man, they suck my box dry.
I see all the attachments.
I mean, there are a bunch of boxes in that other spot.
No one looted the dead kid.
In front of us.
I think they DC'd.
Free kill.
Full finish him, full finish him.
They got the little shield tank.
Let's keep shooting it.
Press Y and then left correct me.
It's T.
It's not much T.
Does this make me a bad person?
No.
Do it.
Did you kill him?
Alright, I'm the good person.
Yeah, you're a good person.
Ow, I got snapped more right!
What?
You guys start from there.
They're on that building R.
Nice shield.
Did they full kill the guy that you bullied?
No.
Yeah.
Oh, you did?
Oh, yeah.
Who was it?
Nice bully.
A power?
Okay.
Nice bully.
Oh, that's why they fall left.
Are you gonna loot?
Yeah, I'm good.
Okay.
Did we get the hill?
Can we get the hill?
I'm gonna grab that guy.
They're shooting my tires!
He has blue.
I don't think he has anything.
We should get on the hill, guys.
We should go on the hill.
I just wanted his attachments and shit.
Why don't we just drive back to the house with five million different death boxes?
Oh my God!
I'm scared.
Where do we drive to?
They're shooting at our car.
I think we need to go up the hill.
We go up the hill.
We go take aight.
Can you go in front of us?
Go straight now.
There's a team up to our 140.
There's a team up to your left.
Be careful.
Okay.
I'm going straight.
And there's a team above us as well.
There's a team straight above us as well.
Turn around.
Go below the bridge and chill.
Let's play low grab, let's play low grab.
Yeah yeah.
He's shooting my car.
AD car, air.
Harry Potter car.
I'm jumping out.
Use as my cars coming.
Ghost prone in a bush!
From the house!
If the car gonna blow it's gonna be real bad, guys.
You're safe by me!
I'm not safe.
Guys, I told you, I can't.
I shouldn't be driving.
I have my... I have my shield, but I'm gonna bleed out pretty fast.
Two more seconds of the shield.
It's okay.
Shift boy's proning.
I got full killed in the smoke, though.
Can you grab that shit?
Yeah.
I'm extracting his juice.
I have smokes in my bag, too, by the way.
They're kind of moving up on you guys.
Nice.
I'm watching.
They're coming in with a car.
Don't get run over.
T3 spawned me.
That's crazy.
Bro, he's gonna squish you.
T3 spawned.
T3 in left.
Bro, that car just kidnapped me.
Yeah.
One close.
I'm in the smoke.
In the smoke.
Shoot this game.
He's prone.
Oh, this is... Wait, was he prone?
That looked like he was down.
Behind you.
No one.
From me.
Pushing from me up here.
He's getting shot in the back.
Hold on.
I can't help you.
From the right.
Three of them from the right.
There's two different teams.
Two different teams.
Just see alive.
Take the car.
Hover away.
Fly away.
Leave us.
Just run.
I don't need the fly mode.
I'm good.
He's got the drive mode.
Goodbye.
He's fine.
Get on that tree.
You're in on that tree.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, he is.
Heal.
This guy is pushing.
They're all kind of naiding you.
They're pushing.
They're all pushing you.
They really want to kill you.
Wait.
They're...
You can press caps and camera switch.
To have a left-hand peek.
There was a team that wanted to rush you.
So, careful.
He's killing them.
I believe.
I believe in...
I thought... There was like a downed message that showed up.
I thought I killed him.
Bro, it's the team we killed, they got respawned because...
We got the time.
Wait, how did they get respawned?
Because the timing.
Because they didn't full die.
Oh.
You get one respawn if it's before a certain time, I think?
Yeah, like, uh, the zone, yeah, like, at a certain time, the respawn gets turned off.
I mean, what do you got?
Top A?
Wait, there's 12 teams.
Wait, two, four, we had seven kills.
And eight, yeah.
Guys, I don't think I should drive, I think.
Yeah, I'm not gonna lie, I thought Shurfer was driving.
I would never get in the car if I knew you were driving.
I wanted to swap seats, to be fair.
Well, sometimes it's better for everyone to have a car, because you don't have to wait.
Yeah, but we were, like, scrambling to get Machap.
So we didn't take up all the cars.
Yeah, and then the one car I got, lost the wheel.
Also, like, does it not show you when you...
Is there a way to show when your car is getting damaged?
Unless, other than, like...
Yeah.
Oh.
It also just looks fucked up.
I know, like, other than the fact that your pieces of your car, like, falls apart, is there, like, any other way to see it?
Yeah, this should be horrible.
I want to be a passenger princess.
14 points, though.
I mean, not bad.
It's horrible.
Yeah.
Wait, how many points do we... What placement do we need to get to tomorrow?
Top... Top six.
The cutoff was, like, 50.
Yeah, it's top six.
Top what?
Top six?
Yeah.
Yeah, the cutoff is 51.
From Oscar.
Yeah, but...
Yeah, we went third before this, so...
With 17 points, we're gonna be at 40 points, though, so...
Yeah, but next game is last game.
Yeah.
LG.
LG, LG.
All right, that first fight, though.
That first fight was fucking crazy.
Sorry, 37 points, not a force.
Pretty good, 7 points.
I dropped my spaghetti everywhere.
What?
During the win?
I thought you had chicken katsu.
Yeah, what about the chicken katsu?
No, I have it in my pockets for later.
Oh.
I dropped it everywhere.
I don't think I shot my... Yeah, I definitely didn't shot my gun during that.
I did better at the end.
With that, all I did was throw my scan, and then you killed people through smoke.
Works fine.
All right, that for me, I just... I was just a res bot.
Res heal, res heal, portal, res.
Honestly, we had a crazy reset in the house that shouldn't have happened.
Yeah.
Then that shotgun went crazy in the house that ain't gonna light it.
Yeah, people just swing in and got two-pumped.
Yup.
Although, I think I killed three people on the stairs then.
Yeah.
Just doink, doink, doink, doink.
In one mag.
Oh.
The DMR, does it have, like, a shot limit?
No.
It shoots as fast as you can click.
Can't you just bind it to scroll wheel?
What?
I didn't even do that!
I mean...
It has absurd recoil though.
Yeah.
Wasn't this someone who used a hotkey?
Well, hopefully the game has macro protection.
Yeah.
The sweats are gonna have some macro set up for that shit.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure people are gonna macro that.
That's okay, none of the macros are in this lobby, right?
I think I'm gonna play Ziva next game.
Okay.
I did get shark girl value this game, but...
Oh, what are you gonna play?
Ziva.
Gibby cat.
Oh.
Oh my god, he's metacrafting right now.
What does the X2 mean?
Oh my god, how many nades does he have?
He's got a lot.
He's still throwing them.
Maybe he has something that refills his nades?
Yeah, like he's still throwing them.
He threw five or six before that.
Yeah.
He has more.
He has no meds then?
He just carries a ton of mollies already.
That guy just threw 15 nades.
We're getting, like, roughly terrible.
I'm pretty sure that guy just died.
Where did he come from?
This guy...
Ronan just blasted off.
This team's just, like...
What is he looking at?
What?
What did he see?
There's, like, a hipfire aiming button there as well.
Yes, there is.
I need to give you the bind for that.
Go to...
Hipfire aiming button?
Yeah.
Go to mouse and keyboard.
Go to custom binds.
And it's called shoulder fire.
Underneath basic combat.
So, like, you hold for hipfire.
What do you bind it to?
I bound it to a side mouse button.
Like, mouse four?
Yeah.
I'm not surprised that they would.
Shoulder fire?
Yeah.
You basically aim it while in third person.
Shoulder fire and ADS or just shoulder fire?
Just shoulder fire.
Shoulder fire and ADS will double bind it.
Yeah.
And make it so, like, you can basically hold right click to shoulder fire and tap right click to go into your sights.
Oh.
That's too complicated.
Guys, I did a lot of damage, even though I felt like I did nothing.
Guys, I improved.
It wasn't 23 damage this time.
Wait, I almost got RPR damage.
I just need 400.
All my damage...
All my damage came from shotgunning, like, three dudes on stairs, dude.
I liked it, dude.
Wait, does it...
You have to...
Is there a new lobby every match?
Wait.
Ever really hates me.
You just declined my friend's request.
Oh, I didn't know you sent me one.
My fault, bro.
Send it?
I thought it was just a recommendation.
No.
Even if it's a recommendation, you weren't gonna accept it.
It's okay.
I'm going to master for me.
That's on me.
That's fucked.
All good, bro.
You're just toxic.
It's a loser.
It's okay.
There has to be losers in the world.
I'm one of them.
Without losers, there wouldn't be any winners.
Yeah, exactly.
They're important.
How are we gonna find out who are the winners?
I'm gonna go dig some ditches.
I'm one of them.
You guys got kicked out of the lobby too?
Every single part of me is replaced.
Will I still be here?
The lobby closes.
Oh, every match?
Okay.
I just wanted to be sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, and they have to tally all the points and whatnot.
Oh, I see.
And then someone doesn't join the lobby for 20 minutes.
Yeah, and then we have to wait for that.
I think like...
I think we spend more time waiting.
That's life.
That is life.
That's life out on the rift.
We're not last.
We better not be last.
After that first game.
I'm not gonna lie, guys.
Using an ability on this high ping, man.
Takes a while, bro.
To put the wall on him away.
Takes me a minute.
It's okay, bro.
It's okay.
It's okay, dude.
You did your best.
And we're proud of you.
I'm not.
Oh.
He's not.
He just hates me, sir.
He's a hater.
He's your biggest hater.
No, I'm a realist.
So he...
He might actually be my biggest hater for whatever reason.
I don't hate.
I appreciate.
And why don't you believe in him?
Because I'll damage them one game.
I'm missing my once a year Minecraft server with my friends for this.
I'm sad.
Minecraft.
Oh, so you don't...
Oh, so you don't want...
I'm missing the annual Minecraft.
You don't want to get paid?
Okay, so...
Oh, man.
So sad...
We need...
To get a top three.
So sad...
That you...
You had to get sponsored today.
Honestly, Saibouted.
That's what I'm saying up here.
Saibouted.
I'm getting training right now.
I'm missing fucking Minecraft.
You could just join Minecraft later.
It's still there.
It's not like they're gonna close the survey.
No, you gotta be there right at the start.
You gotta be there at the right armorer.
Yeah, exactly, bro.
They've already killed the under dragon.
But tell them to stop!
If they are your friends, they will stop.
It's over.
Not real.
Not real bros.
Who the fuck are these guys in my training?
What?
All the...
small things.
You got, like, random people in your training room?
Yeah.
How did that happen?
Happens in Apex, too.
It's a pretty universal BR bug, I guess.
Whoa!
Hey, guys.
Look at the skins, guys, that you can buy.
Oh my god, they have a gotcha.
Yeah, they do.
Oh my god.
This game is for you.
I definitely haven't done 40 pulls on it.
Wait, you already did pulls?
I know this game's a gotcha.
Yeah, they give you...
How did you?
If you go to the, uh...
Type bar?
The event tab on the right, and you go to daily perks, they give you a thousand credits every day.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Really?
You can do that, or you can just stockpile them and buy the skins you want.
We should stockpile them.
I've been doing pulls, because I'm a gambling man.
I wanna...
Wait, the lobby's open.
I wanna do pulls.
It's an event on the right?
You can do it after, because the lobby's open, and they're gonna yell at you.
Yeah, but I'm...
Okay, but I won't be the last person.
They're gonna yell at you.
You can't yell at me if I'm not last.
They can, and they will.
And they won't.
I'm first.
I'm first on our team, because I'm the best.
First one to die.
Wait, I can't go fourth slot?
Where's the event?
Are you sure it's top, right?
Yeah, yeah, not like top top right, but like main menu, right hand side of your screen, like towards the top, but underneath the leaderboards and mailbox and stuff.
Oh, oh, I see it.
I see it.
Yeah.
Holy blind.
Okay.
Guys, type in this code so I can get...
I can't even sell off that.
It's shameless.
Holy shit.
Guys, use my referral code.
Yeah, use my referral code.
Guys, type in this shit.
Get four free holes and a glider.
Do you guys see this?
First thing she did, bro.
Type in this code, man.
Type in this code.
Also, click on my link pinned in my chat so you can wishlist this game right now.
Because if you guys forgot, we are sponsored.
Hashtag end.
Make sure you wishlist the game yourselves.
Alright, I'm getting it.
Oh, I claimed Mindy.
Nice.
Gratz.
I got it.
Oh, claim her.
Oh my god.
I got pulls by adding friends.
Alright.
I'm gonna do my pull.
Uh...
How do I do this pull?
Okay.
Ten pulls.
Confirmed.
What did I get?
What are these?
Oh, I think I got like an emote.
I couldn't tell.
Okay.
Gotta make sure I don't leak the password like somebody here.
I don't know.
Someone almost got the password correct.
In my chat.
Now we're giving out hints to the password.
Just a couple more digits, guys.
Just a couple more.
I mean, to be fair, it's between boobs and the other one.
Because you're hot and you're cold.
Solve my riddle.
I think our group was definitely the easier group.
Group A looked like a lot of sweats.
Nah, we win.
Yeah, that's why our group is easier.
No, we win in Group A.
I'm in Group A.
I think the people who are in the top six literally were playing this game every day since closed beta launched.
Yeah, same as us.
Yeah, sure for it.
How many hours?
1,000.
Alright.
Screenshot.
Right now.
And my screenshot keybind is broken.
Show it on stream then.
Right now.
That button's broken too.
Oh.
Okay.
How about Discord screen share?
I can't do that.
Why not?
My computer blows up.
It does?
Yeah.
Is it like 100% chance or is it like a 50-50?
It's like 100%.
Oh, that's rough, buddy.
I had someone, like, do something where they, like, optimize my PC and...
Yeah!
Who recommended you the optimization?
I don't know.
I found it on, uh, Craigslist.
Oh.
What's his name?
I mean, if he fucked up your PC, you can just dox him and ruin his life.
Huh?
I mean...
That's always an option.
Yeah.
I mean, he ruined your PC.
Why don't you just ruin his life now?
I don't know.
Hmm.
What?
Suska emoji.
Do you feel bad for him?
Yes.
I feel bad for the common man.
Why?
While living in this trap.
We don't choose to get brought in.
And we can't choose when to get brought out.
We can't choose when to get brought out.
Well...
You guys implying something?
I didn't say anything!
I just...
What do you mean?
What are you implying?
I didn't say anything.
You guys trying to say something here?
Or...
I didn't say anything.
What about you, Mac?
What were you trying to say?
Lightning strikes.
Keep yourself safe.
Trifor taught me that.
What is the meaning behind that, Trifor?
You like keeping yourself safe?
Yeah.
Yeah, because you like speaking in, like, metaphors and shit.
Metaphors?
Yeah.
That one isn't a metaphor.
What is it?
What am I talking about?
You have a higher chance dying walking outside than staying inside, so you have to keep yourself safe.
Yeah.
That's what I meant.
You gotta make sure you're safe inside.
You gotta keep yourself safe tonight?
Always.
Always safe.
Gotta be extra protected.
I'm not a risk taker.
Yeah.
Always wear protection.
Huh?
What?
To keep yourself safe.
Huh?
Yeah, make sure you're armored up.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What?
I lock mine.
Huh?
You just need to bail someone.
Only Jesus has the key.
Fuck.
He's married to God, guys.
He's keeping himself safe with God.
We're all here.
We're all here now.
We should start when- Oh, they're doing countdown!
Seven, six, five, four, three, two, three, two, just to make sure we all get started on the same, same track.
Last game.
Yay!
Let's go out with a bang.
Let's end this with a dub.
Yay!
What place are we at now?
We don't know.
They never- Oh, no.
Wait.
My mod showed, sent it to me.
We are fifth place.
We're- Oh, no.
We're two points ahead of sixth place.
Okay.
It's coming down to the wire.
Wait behind us.
Yeah.
We're locked in.
If we just kill everyone in this lobby, we're good.
Yeah.
That's all we have to do.
Kill them all, don't die.
And then don't let me drive.
You don't die?
I think I'm going to die.
Don't let me drive, guys.
That's all that matters.
Guys, if we're the last team alive, then we won.
So, let's do that.
That's true.
Pretty simple.
I think about it.
We're starting on the right.
I mean, we just go observatory again.
Just riding it out.
Just go there.
Actually, yeah.
We can- Yeah, you can do that.
Yeah.
Do we- I don't think we make that, actually.
Could we jump- Nah, we do.
We just got to stretch it.
I think I'm all right on testing that.
Mack, you're the best player.
You should go for it.
You can do it, I believe.
I'll stretch it.
I stretch.
I mean, if we land on any of these portals, there should be a car.
I mean, we could just go here.
There's going to be a car.
There's going to be a car on either side of these portals.
I believe.
Yeah, we could just go here.
Yeah, for that.
I'm still believing.
Wait, people are laughing on each other.
Wait, people are griefing.
Wait, they're actually griefing for points.
Yeah.
They're actually griefing for points right now.
Us.
Yay.
There's a vehicular.
Yeah, there's always a vehicle at the portals.
I think I'm lagging.
Yeah, someone is.
No, I think Mac is.
Oh.
No.
Because we're attached to him.
I have 40 ping.
I think it just looks like that.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Hello, everybody.
It's like a... Like a... Dude, you're wasting fuel.
We're gonna find more cops.
We're going on a road trip.
Dude, you're wasting fuel.
We're on a road trip, everyone.
Complaining at his backseat driver in my fucking face.
Turn on the AC.
Now.
I'm stuck with Doki.
Are we there yet?
Holy shit.
We're fucked over here.
Are we there yet?
Just drop me off with that armored car.
I'm gonna go through the... The north place.
I'm gonna drive this car into the fucking wall.
You're just farming for kills.
You're so smart.
Why didn't we do that?
You turned off your car too, or what?
Why didn't my car just do that?
Was that cool?
AC is off the... Wait, why is the AC off?
Don't deserve it.
Global warming.
Wait.
Our fuel is wasting fuel right now.
There's 15 cars here.
Yeah, but you're wasting fuel.
What if I find a fuel cell?
What then?
Then... Then we're not wasting fuel.
But we are currently... I can't.
I can't.
I'm gonna lose it.
Can I get the jet car and just run people over?
He can.
I mean, you could do it right now and then, like, respawn.
Really?
Just respawn back here.
Yeah, yeah, we'll respawn.
If you die, you respawn.
Yeah.
Really?
You know, the downside is you give other people kills.
Yeah.
No, I'm lying.
Yeah, typical RPR.
I'm not surprised.
Yeah, alright.
There it is.
I dropped a blue helmet.
Yeah, RPR doesn't care for the environment.
He just wants to waste gas.
What the fuck did I do?
He just want to waste fuel.
That's a bad message.
He's an electric car.
RPRs are very impressionable.
That's a very bad message.
It's an electric car.
You don't know that.
Okay.
It's a king.
It's the future.
Trying to say it's a Tesla?
He hates the Earth.
He does.
I bet he has bad...
Zone came to us.
Oh, yeah.
That's good.
Oh my god.
How come I can't use this?
Hello?
Let me use this.
Okay.
She's struggling to loot.
I'm trying to use...
I don't know.
It was pointless.
It was pointless for me to say it.
Hello, guys.
I don't have a gladiator yet and I'm not comfortable with that.
There's an AK here.
There's a DMR too.
Think about it.
I have a DMR right now.
You don't even have a point.
I'm very far.
Wait.
Why are you so far from us?
The other POI.
Oh.
Maximizing.
That's for point of interest, by the way.
For those who don't know.
That's a gamer term.
Yeah.
Only real gamers know.
Only real gamers know what POIs is.
I gotta explain it to the common man.
Guys, what's the SITREP?
The fuck are we talking about now?
It stands for Situation Report.
Jesus Christ.
What is it?
Yeah.
What is the SITREP?
So no SITREP or?
I'm looting, dude.
Currently I'm looting too.
Heard.
What about on the other end?
What about on the other side?
I just got DMR, I guess.
Guys, if we have builders, we can set up a FOB.
Yeah?
What is that?
Playing fucking squad.
That sounds for Forward Operating Base.
Yeah, I'm ironically used that in fucking Rust, by the way.
Wait, really?
At how many hours do we have to set up a FOB?
What's the military time for it?
It doesn't matter.
It's gonna get offline raided.
Jesus.
Boink yeah.
How is Jesus's word- participar?
Like, what the fuck?
You're using his name in vain.
I'm shouting out to my boy Jesus.
Yeah, they're best friends.
He knows him personally.
I'm shouting out to him.
Giving him a shout out.
He paid for it.
Yeah, well, I just got sponsored by Jesus.
Yeah, sponsored by Jesus, by the way.
Hashtag Jesus.
Hashtag ad.
How would you know, huh?
Are you good friends with Jesus?
VTubers are against God's creation.
Holy shit.
But you're a VTuber too.
It is said not to make false idols of yourself.
I'm not an idol.
And a VTuber is literally a false idol.
No, I'm not.
You're going against the vision of God.
Oh shit.
And why are you interacting with VTubers?
Oh, I'm a sinner.
Oh, you're a sinner?
Can I get a gladiator?
You're not going to ask God to forgive you?
Well, right before I die, I ask for forgiveness.
Yeah, so you're collecting... So you're collecting all of it.
Collecting all the sins before you... I'm sin-maxing.
Yeah.
So right before you die, you get a priest over and be like, please God, forgive me.
For I've sinned.
What if you die before he fully forgives you?
Then I'm stuck in limbo.
Because what if the loading time is too much?
They send me to the back room.
The load time?
Yeah.
The loading time.
Like, what's the upload down the speed of your prayer?
They probably got a terabyte internet out there.
You think so?
They're closer to the satellites.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
That's what it is?
Do they have fiber?
Is there fiber prayer time?
But isn't there a queue, though?
There might be a queue.
Is there a lot of gladiators?
Yeah, the waiting room.
I got the fast pass.
Yeah, the fast pass.
How did you get the fast pass?
Sure, play.
I got a premium.
Oh, yeah.
Forgive me, premium.
I use my faith points.
Damn, he allocated his faith points into premium.
Yeah, he maxed out.
Tracking.
Oh, my God.
I see you.
Wait, Mac, Mac, Mac, Mac.
How can I not find a gladiator, dude?
You can't find one because you're new.
Okay.
I just want one.
Oh, you're your own dumbass.
Dude, don't talk to yourself like that.
I have so many smokes.
Good.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Deploying airdrop.
Okay, I can do healing app.
Are you guys at the juicer juicing it?
I am.
Oh, I got healing app.
Let's go.
That's good for us.
Is that the acid shit that when you get hit, you keep getting hit?
Some shit.
Oh, I got first aid and healing app.
Let's go.
I got the support stuff.
There's a care pad coming.
We have a harmonizer because we should go for that.
Hold on.
I got to go shop as well.
All right, smoke cover, source strain.
Okay, maybe I can get the auto charge.
I'm ready to be a heal bot, guys.
And I got source strain.
You can grab the car and then go for a harmonizer.
Okay, that requires me to defeat an enemy.
I don't think that's useful.
No problem.
All right, we should head to sure floor.
I mean, we could trade armors if you want.
I'll take the source strain and shit.
Yeah, sure.
I'll give it to you.
Oh, you can have one.
I'm going to impact.
All right.
I thought we're trading here because you stopped.
Yeah, we'll trade.
We'll trade.
All right.
We'll be crazy.
While we're swapping, we get three, two, one.
Yeah.
That would be a goddamn tragedy.
He's swerving.
It's kind of sick right here.
Yeah, sure.
For the faith build.
Yeah, he's been doing that since he was born.
He's scammed us.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let's be boy.
Oh, I fucked up.
I think he tried.
He tried to scan.
Are we fighting now?
What's going on?
I can do a portal for sure for him.
But I don't know if he'll live.
I need a portal for sure, or are you good?
Yeah, I probably need it.
I'm not near my car, and I'm scammed.
All right.
And I'm dead.
Get out and drop it.
He's got the shield on him.
Okay.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
He should be able to take it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Hold H on it.
I'm holding H from getting thirsty.
I don't think he's...
You got it.
Yeah, I have fast res.
I have fast res.
That was close.
Yeah, that was.
Here.
I'm a crap bomb.
Born again.
Oh, my God.
I got shot at.
Um, what the fuck?
What the fucky?
We only have one car now?
No, no, we have a car in the smoke.
There's a car in the smoke.
I'm just kidding.
Wait, oh, okay, so we didn't take that car in the smoke.
If we get a pick, we should try to kill them.
I almost killed them.
One of them is on blue armor.
We should kill them before they get this shit because they're gonna have good armors.
Yeah.
I don't have another res.
One's on earth.
I think they got it.
That's a gun from the...
We're leaving, we're leaving, we're leaving.
Yeah, get out, get out, get out, get out.
These guys are sweat loads.
Can we get a different harmonizer?
I can give a heal to Surefire.
No, there's only two on the map.
Mac, you good?
I can't talk because I got shot.
I'm gonna wall out around.
Yeah, I'll be fine.
I walled off our bush.
We're good.
Okay, we have to take...
There's another car right here.
Yeah.
Um, I can give another heal.
I'm giving it to Mac.
They are pushing, they're pushing.
I'm going to hold this compound.
I'm in this compound.
Ok, you guys wanna take this car before I...
Ok, I'm...
I knock one, I knock one, I knock one.
I'm knocked.
Oh, RP you need to pick us up.
Uh oh.
They are going to run you over.
Oh, I hit it.
Why can't you come back cracked?
I ulted my feet.
I'm dead.
I'm so fucking dead, dude.
There's no way I can see AD.
I'm flashing.
I'm so fucking flashing.
I'm gonna do maximum damage here.
Yeah, we got second red.
We have to die.
Killed one.
Oh, it's Aiden's group again.
We have second res though.
Yeah, we respawn.
I gripped the shit out of them.
Well, we also needed to get picked up on the car.
Oh, we're respawning next to them.
We're respawning next to them.
Go to the Harmonizer.
Just go to the Harmonizer.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Oh, it didn't change my spawn.
You didn't need to change it.
You just did change it.
I changed it, and then I tried to change it back.
Are they gonna go back to it?
There's a car here.
Wait, where are you?
I'm gonna take this car.
You know, if we were four, I would agree with you.
But we're two.
Yeah.
I thought the one that swapped was you, Mac.
That's why...
I'm driving over.
Me too.
You wanna finish this?
Yeah, I mean, we could try.
I'm driving over too.
Try to finish it.
I got the pumpy.
I may die.
I have a bolt-action and auto-shot it.
Because I don't trust myself.
Just go down there and start tapping it.
I'm tapping.
Oh, I see them coming.
Uh-oh.
Are we fighting?
Maybe.
If they hit you, they're gonna know you're wide and bloated.
I hit one for 110.
Um...
We're coming up.
One is driving up with two dudes in it.
Why not?
Yeah.
That car has two in it.
Are they coming up?
It does as smooth as me.
No, not yet.
You guys stand in here so it's faster, please.
They're starting to drive up.
No, no, no, no.
I don't have...
I only have a Jackson.
Is there any extra guns?
Can you ping where they're coming from at least?
Up here.
I'm just gonna heal Mac right now.
Yeah.
Should be good to cap.
It doesn't look like they're gunning it.
Okay, I did, I did, I did.
Last cap, last cap.
Time for a grand entrance.
Gen collector.
That's good, right?
What is this?
Yeah, that's good.
That means if some of us die, you run away.
I'm gonna check the roof for extra guns.
I also have an ultimate accelerator.
Who needs ult?
I'm a drop ultimate accelerator.
I think they're playing Sorrowind.
Be careful.
They could...
They could fly in on a roof.
I'm just trying to get extra guns.
Yeah, we can go back to our bodies.
Yeah, let's go back to our bodies after this.
Just cap this and then go back to our bodies.
Can someone stand with point with me so it's faster, guys?
It's almost done.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm running down now.
Yeah, I was just trying to rewatch and make sure they don't fly on us.
So yeah, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over here now.
I'm already here.
Yeah, I'm here.
They went up here.
They're definitely just getting upgrades.
Okay.
Time to put our plans in motion.
Yippee.
I got gold up, dude.
Grab that SMG in the TP.
I'll get that emergency shield.
Take in Tempest.
There's a...
Taking the armor card here.
Who's with me?
Alright.
I'll go with Max.
Okay.
Let's go back to our bodies.
I hope they're still not there, though.
They shouldn't.
They drove up to the right.
We died like...
Oh, there's someone here at the compound.
I used armor.
I think it's a different team.
It is a different team.
We might even be able to kill these guys.
If we can get to our bodies, we can get good armors and kill them, no?
I can smoke it in three seconds.
I'm gonna go up the hill and see if I can type them in a second.
Okay.
I'll have a portal if we need it.
Yeah, I can also put a wall on it.
I don't have any scope, so like...
This car is fucked.
They're driving.
We should kill these guys, bro.
They have sniper.
They don't have white armor.
I really feel like we should take this fight, dude.
Yeah, I mean, you can try and see if you can get your body.
I'm gonna...
I can't do anything.
I'm going down to the left.
If you have smokes...
Bodies are here.
There's another car driving up on our right.
They're flying.
Did these guys flying?
No, that's the supply drop.
Oh, the supply drop, yeah.
There's a car trying to come up on our right.
Are you guys okay over there?
I almost killed one.
They're out on our right.
I got knocked.
This is a different team.
Can you res?
No.
Car.
For me.
I know I have what.
They're running away.
They're flying away.
They're flying.
Aw, my God, bro.
I killed one.
I got a heal.
There's a car on me.
I almost knocked one.
Oh, there's someone behind us.
Car, car, car, car!
Car behind you!
You're trying to run over.
I'm smoking it.
I'm a slow gun.
He's executing me in the bush!
Oh no.
That's not good.
I almost killed one in this other car.
Smoke's over.
The first one's over.
One's on the body.
I'm gonna slow heal.
I just fell.
Yeah, Mac might need help later.
I'm coming.
I'm just...
I've all killed one.
Oh, in the body.
I killed one in the body.
Killed one on Shuford's body.
Can I get res?
Hold on, hold on.
I'm getting him.
He's on top of your car.
Yeah.
They're wrapping us.
Okay.
Come to the side.
They're going up above us.
I'm crawling.
They are.
Wait.
You can tee me.
I'm sticking your house.
I'm running through this and spawning him.
Break time's over.
Welcome back to this fight.
RPR, you need to put a wall down on my side.
I don't have wall in 10 seconds.
I'm getting shot through the wall, bro.
Yeah, they have us on the stand.
Run.
You have to run.
RPR has to run.
I do, I do.
Yeah, just run.
Run, run.
Just get out.
You'll be able to grab all of us.
I don't have much heals.
They might try to drive.
Just hide.
Hide in the bush.
Dude, prone.
In the bush.
Z in the bush.
Do I heal?
They might use the lipstick, though.
They're just looting our dead bodies.
They might just, like, uh, throw the lipstick, though.
Do you have enough heals, though, for this?
No.
Definitely not.
Can I grab it from here with gem collector?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just pop it.
So who do I get?
It works.
It's a whole team.
We all have heals on our boxes, so it's fine.
Oh, you're grabbing me right now.
You gonna spawn me?
You have meds, like, to begin with, right?
You said you just have a lot.
That's it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll be fine.
We can get up to the bodies.
And there's also bodies down there.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go grab a car.
I still hit a car by the bodies, by the way.
The first team might have came back and grabbed the guy's banner that I killed.
How much meds do you have left, though?
Two meds.
Oh, you have to go now, then, or you're gonna die in the storm.
Yeah, I do.
And then Matt can grab the meds on our old bodies.
Yeah, that's just our old...
Oh, there's people here.
There's a guy healing in the storm here.
You have to heal, you have to heal.
100 out of 10.
I'm gonna add this on too, bro.
My last heal.
I jumped into that car.
I'm just dead.
I just have no heals.
There's no heals on any of these bodies, dude.
No, they took all the heals.
I spawned and it said I had 9 heals.
That's so weird.
Dude, I spawned and it said I had 9 heals, but then I had 2.
Why aren't these guys still here?
I don't know.
What are they doing?
I think they absorbed all our...
I think they were rezzing.
Yeah, they absorbed all our heals.
I kind of got fucked up when I was trying to scan and then the car left me.
I shouldn't have jumped out of the car with a scan.
Yeah.
I don't think it does.
I tried scanning through the window once and it wouldn't let me.
These guys are so dead.
The guy, nope, couldn't get arrested.
He's dead.
I mean, all of them lived.
Oh, wait.
He's dead.
Never mind.
Like on my screen, it doesn't show him dead.
On the...
I mean on the like the...
the team thing.
You know what?
They're gonna die for doing that.
Look!
He's stuck in car!
Car's stuck!
Oh yeah!
It's worth it!
You know what?
That's what they get for camping us out.
That's what they get.
Oh, they're cooked.
What are they gonna do?
Yeah.
There's only one...
The last rat is just gonna rat.
That's the rat.
That's what they get for camping our bodies.
Oh!
He got smoked!
That's what they get!
Karma!
Actual karma!
Dessert.
I don't think...
Guys, I don't know.
I don't think we made it to the top five...
Guys, I don't think we're top six.
I don't think so.
It's okay.
You can blame me.
I think fuck we can blame him, dude.
Yeah, thank fuck, guys.
I'll take it.
Yeah.
You'll take it.
Maybe they'll give us a...
Maybe...
They're like, we gotta put this team in because they're the sponsored team.
I don't think they're gonna do that.
Wait, we got...
How many kills did I have?
Zero.
I think I have two.
I don't know how to say it.
You had one.
You pressed base bar.
You can't see mine.
You had four knocks.
Only one kill, though.
You had two...
Two kills.
Two kills and...
It backed me out of the game.
We got nine points for this game.
I was crawling on the ground simulator.
I don't think...
That guy just got three, two, one.
Yeah.
That's fucked.
Which puts us at 46 points.
Which...
I don't think we made it.
The teams below what the cutoff was before.
Because, like, the...
The teams below us...
The teams below us were very close to catching up to us.
They literally just had the...
Placement points.
And that...
Jesus Christ!
What the...
Yeah!
I was gonna say, what the fuck are they doing?
Bro, look...
Look, these guys are just running people over.
They're just running people over.
Why didn't we run people over?
Why were we the ones that get run over?
Because we were the ones always getting pushed.
Except in the first game.
They should make it in this game.
So if you get run over under, like, 80 kilometers an hour, you do not take damage.
Yeah, you can kind of just, like...
I don't think that's real life.
Pace and still run people over.
Yeah, you can run...
You can do 20 kilometer hours...
Instamox.
It's kind of nuts.
That's crazy.
You just go armored car, hit your armor ability, and just point, point, point.
Play...
Falling with them.
Yeah.
I definitely should not have peeked the...
Them when they first drove up to us.
I got gunned down.
Then I reset.
And then I got shot from three different directions.
I just got shot at with my white army.
Oh, these guys are a different zone, aren't they?
Also, like, we kept bumping into Aiden's team, too.
Or Aiden's team.
Yeah.
Well, yeah.
It's because we fought them at the start.
Wait.
And didn't...
Didn't Mac invite that item, too?
So, like, you literally...
So you...
So you invited him, just so we could die.
Because they weren't originally in the tournament.
In the official tournament roster.
You did this post.
That's my bad.
I should've taken off my belt.
I can't believe it.
Mac invited him just for...
Just for him to kill us.
There is an imposter among us.
I'm a fucking double agent.
Yeah, the double agent.
He wanted...
He rather...
You're actually grieving.
You know, you could've made money.
Look, they're alive again.
This is your fault.
No respect to them.
Look, see, they're alive.
No, it's my freaking fault.
There's your friend.
Mac, there's your friend.
Yeah, sure.
You don't even know him.
It's my freaking fault.
Wait, wait.
They're in first.
It's actually good if they soak up all the points.
It is, yeah.
We might make it.
Are you sure?
Yeah, yeah.
If they soak up the points...
Yeah, no, but I meant like...
The teams below us, I think...
Have placements.
Yeah, but if they kill everyone and they win, it might be doable.
I wish I could see.
I didn't say it was gonna be comfortable, but we might make it.
For sure I just crashed.
You just crashed?
I mean...
I...
I feel like we're gonna...
Okay.
I feel like we're gonna like...
Lose by one point.
Judging our luck.
Can I like get back in?
You know, probably not.
Yeah.
Why did they put Aiden and Vayne together?
Wait, that's fucked.
Yeah, they signed up as a team.
That's...
That's fucked.
The initial team...
And you invited both of them too!
The initial team?
Okay, okay.
The team I invited, it actually would've been way worse.
It was supposed to be Frex, Vayne, Aiden, and Solve.
You invited both of these players!
That's in the first place!
I can't believe you've done this!
Yeah, I can't believe you've done this!
You did this to us!
I just wanted to be known, Doki invited me.
So...
Thank you for your Doki!
I had a sponsor opportunity!
I can't believe you've done that, Doki!
I had a...
They were like...
I can't believe you've done this!
Oh!
Why didn't you suggest a fourth player?
You two could've suggested a fourth player!
You guys didn't!
I was never asked!
You're literally captain!
You're literally captain, RPR!
I was never asked!
Guys, we're a team.
We need to stop fighting.
Yeah.
It's all Surefour's fault!
The game's over!
Yeah, it's my fault.
It's all his fault!
I agree.
You're right.
Yeah, in the end it was Surefour's fault.
I should've been freaking stronger.
You should've...
Why did you get out of the car, Surefour?
Because I wanted to scan.
And then I got gunned down.
I mean, I looked it and it didn't look like there was a yellow beam and they baited us.
Yeah, they activated it as we pulled out.
Yeah, they activated it, yeah.
That's why Mac and I drove off.
I think we got timing.
Yeah, which team won?
I can't believe we got timing when we were baited.
I wish we could see the leader board, like the... what placement each person got.
Yeah.
I had 97 damage.
I got MEP in our team.
Well, I can report you.
Congrats, bro.
I can report Mac.
What the?
Report Doki for InstaCode.
I should report SureFor it, because we're all blaming him, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It was 100% SureFor's fault.
Why weren't you stronger?
I don't know.
I didn't have enough Jesus points stacked.
I didn't use your faith points to help us.
I need to save them from when I die.
Right before you die, or else you can't be forgiven.
Maybe God has gotcha up there.
Get 20 pulls.
What would your pulls be?
Like, what kind of angels are around you?
What kind of angels?
Yeah, he gets to pick his wings, bro.
And his halo.
How do we find out if we're clankers or not?
Um...
They post the results, like, soon.
I mean, they have to calculate it.
Chat.
What were the...
Do you guys know who were the last top five teams?
Then we'll know.
Like, the...
Vayne got second.
Yeah, who was first?
Who was the team that got first, guys?
In the last game.
Hopefully the team that's in front of us, not behind us.
Yeah, hopefully.
I don't know.
Yeah, I'm pulling for five-star SSR Zachariah.
What the fuck he said, Dom Dom?
I don't know what he said.
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, I just rolled for Moses.
Someone was like, the one with Iden.
That's me!
You should roll for Jesus, bro.
Not for Moses.
You can't roll for Jesus, bro.
Why can't he?
Isn't Jesus SSR?
No, Jesus is, like, the announcer of, like, the game.
You don't roll for them.
They're, like, the main character.
Wait, then what's God?
God's, like, the creator.
The cre...
Oh, he's the dev?
Oh, he's the dev.
Will I still be, Camille?
So, God's the dev.
Oh, shit.
Jesus is, like, the announcer.
Then what about, like...
Then what can you roll for?
Apostles, I guess.
Like, the people that die.
The angels, the saints.
Wait, does that mean we can roll for Surefour?
Lucifer.
Roll for SSR Lucifer.
You can roll for Lucifer?
Like, the commons would be...
The commons would be, like...
Like, Surefour in them.
There's usually, like, darker shadow types in gotchas.
So, like, Lucifer fix it.
Jokey can only learn about the Bible.
I know about the Bible.
And then there's, like...
Then there's also, like...
The...
The holy version of Lucifer before the falling.
Yeah?
How so?
Yeah.
Well, Lucifer is a fallen angel.
Oh, is it would be, like, a different skin or, like, a different character?
Yeah, yeah.
Just different character?
Do you like that?
Like, like...
Yeah, like, you know.
The cosmetics.
It's a chroma.
It's a chroma dude.
Hey.
What happened?
Is it blasphemous to make a gotcha based off of the Bible?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Is that?
I feel like you can make so much money off of that.
Like, if you have no morals.
Because you're making money off of it.
Yeah.
Is it blasphemous if, like, a priest makes it?
What if a priest got in the game dev?
Wait, who owns the Bible?
Like, you know, like, the Bible's...
Who wrote this?
What?
The Bible's not?
No.
Like, currently, like, because, like, the Bible is like the...
The...
It's open source.
Yeah, but, like, where does the profit of the Bible goes to?
The profits of the Bible?
Yeah.
Because, like, the Bible is...
You're asking questions.
Does this go straight to the Vatican?
Like, does the Pope earn from the sales of the Bible?
I just want to know.
People have to pay for the bible.
There's no royalties in heaven.
They don't use... There are royalties in heaven.
You have to pay tithe.
Hey, we got it.
This guy doesn't know what a tithe is.
I don't want to know.
I'm not going to heaven anyway.
How do you know that?
Just ask to be forgiven.
I just know I ain't.
You don't know that.
I don't want to be forgiven.
Ask to be forgiven.
Store up your faith points.
Why not?
I don't want to be forgiven.
God is inside of everyone.
Yeah.
You just have to let him in.
I'm not letting him inside me.
They're prostrating themselves for Jesus.
But you let Surefour inside of you.
So why can't you let God inside of you?
Huh?
Remember when you were like Surefour is inside me?
You said that.
I didn't say that.
Guys, clip it.
I remember that.
I do not remember what you were saying.
I remember that because it was turned to hell house.
When we were all getting shot at.
See, my chat remembers.
This is what you're focusing on instead of killing the enemy.
I was pressing and healing all of you.
No.
What do you mean?
This is what we lost.
I made so many portals to fucking save your asses.
I died for the same people every time.
Yeah, the vein spot that Mack invited.
I was just crawling on ground simulator.
So when do we know when we lost?
We got told to back up.
Me and fucking...
I think like, remember when we...
Hiding behind a tree as RPR can just pick us up in a car and he drives away.
And we just get fucking off aimed with three different people.
What happened to us like positioning?
Why were we just running at people?
I'm sorry.
I didn't know that my teammate with the car seeing his two people out in the open as they're getting pushed would need to say hey.
I didn't see you guys.
I was getting shot, man.
Yeah, just like you didn't see Avarelli's icon when you fucking mag dumped his car.
I didn't.
I smoked him though.
He got fucking cooked, bro.
No, but like...
Sure, for your...
Actually, I blame RPR.
This guy's a third agent.
You guys should've said...
Actually, I remember when we were in that one place we always drop at, I saw him vent.
You know, that's good enough for me.
Let's vote him off.
This guy sends himself and Doki to a dead fucking island on the fucking beam.
Then he fucking blames me.
And Avarelli invites a fucking enemy to the fucking tournament that kills us four times.
And it's my fault.
It is your fault.
You are the captain RPR.
Hey, put your hand up if you're European.
Oh, not putting my hand up.
Hey, Canada came from Europe, bro.
You got European roots?
No, I don't.
I definitely do not.
We made you.
I definitely don't have European roots.
We made you guys.
Okay.
You're not even part of the Europe that made Canada.
You're not even part of that Europe.
You're so far from the UK.
You're literally is an ocean dividing you.
I'm closer than you.
You have an ocean dividing you.
What breed are you again?
I can report him and he gets banned and all that.
You're saying we like your French.
Don't ever call me French again in life.
Damn.
You're literally closer to France than you are to the UK.
It's about the same.
That's not the same.
There's literally an ocean dividing.
What do you know about geography?
I know that UK is an island.
Huh?
Yeah.
It's a giant ass island.
UK is an island?
Yes.
It's surrounded by...
Okay, Mac, you're fucking...
No, it's surrounded by the ocean.
It's surrounded by the ocean.
Wait, am I?
What are you...
Wait, no.
You didn't know that?
It's literally a fucking...
Well, let me know what you know.
Hey.
Actually, we all came from this thing.
What do you know about Europe, Mac?
Actually, we all came from the same place because of Pangea.
That's the only parts of Europe that I know is the Nordic parts.
We're all from Pangaea before the Reckoning.
Let's listen about Max's Europe knowledge.
Do you think Jesus was more of like a velociraptor when he first spawned?
Guys, we don't have to show up for day two, guys.
We're freed.
Do you think dinosaurs had their own Jesus?
Oh, we missed it by five.
Yeah, we missed it by five.
At least it was at one point.
Did you know that T-Rexes had like a two-kilometer vision and they were completely silent?
So you could be getting stalked by a T-Rex for like hours, not even known.
Then it could just be right behind you.
Damn.
Well, how do you know that?
Were humans even alive back then?
I found that out because of TikTok.
Oh, you believe?
How did they know that?
Yeah, I was going to say, you just believe random TikTok videos?
It's like, I just learned this from YouTube short.
Do you think people would go on the internet and just lie?
I mean, RPR is here.
I mean, look at Linkster, bro.
That guy lies 247, dude.
Who would make fake educational problems?
He's a whole ass fanboy.
That's true.
Wait, are you trying to say fanboys lie?
No, you're saying that particular fanboy.
I'm not a fucking fanboy, dude.
There you are.
Yeah, but you've been a fanboy in VR chat.
Definitely are.
I've seen you in the maid outfit.
I'm not a fucking fanboy.
Oh, true!
You've cosplayed more as women characters than men.
And I was the manliest maid ever made.
Like, what do we want about it?
Wait, question.
Have you ever worn thigh highs, RPR?
Yeah.
No.
Don't lie.
He had to think about it.
Yeah, yeah, no.
It wasn't, yeah.
He had to think about it.
No, I was fucking hitting my vape.
Femboy.
You were hitting your vape.
I'm sure you were.
Yeah, I need to calm down when I talk to you guys.
You could have changed teams.
The staff were like, are you okay with playing with X and X person?
And then you could have said no.
No, they literally told me this is your team and I said aight.
Wait, really?
They were like, do you want to play with the RPR and Sherpaugh?
I was like, yeah, this is gonna be your team.
And I was like, aight.
Damn, and you're the captain.
You saw the RPR on the list and you were just like, fuck.
I was like, fuck hell, man.
I feel like I was like, I feel like I was the only one that like, got asked about my opinion.
Yeah, and it's my fucking team, apparently.
Yeah, you're the captain.
How am I the captain?
I didn't do fucking shit, dude.
I'm the captain.
I didn't do anything, dude.
How am I the captain?
Oh yeah, Vayne got 115 points.
Thanks, Mac.
That's good.
That was my bad.
Yeah, they almost went in with an actual killing squad, too.
Well, we don't have to go tomorrow.
Alright, GG's, guys.
It was fun.
Yeah, also, guys, just so you guys remember, you can download the link.
Not download, you can wishlist this game.
Yeah, you can wishlist this game.
Clicking the link in the penned message.
You can also go store, and then type fate trigger, and then go...
Yeah, and it's free to play.
And if you watched our stream, you guys might have got keys to play the game yourself.
Because look, the friendship in this group has never been so strong before.
Wait, wait, we should all gift each other.
Oh, yo, check my code, guys.
No, no, no.
Use my code.
Guys, use my code right here.
What the fuck is a holographic rose?
She's being assaulted.
I don't have one.
I'm a loser.
What you don't have?
A holographic rose.
What's a holographic rose?
I don't know.
You can give people...
Wait, really?
Roses in this game.
Oh, so that's what it was.
Wait, how do you...
You can marry people in this game.
Wait, marry like the...
Wait, really?
The characters that we have?
No, your friends.
Wait, what?
What?
Yeah, click on the friends list.
Will there be like a wedding ceremony?
No, click on the friend thing.
Yeah.
And then like click on any of your friends.
Wait, why are you guys offline?
I closed the game.
I might have closed the game.
Oh, okay.
Just click on anyone.
Okay.
Close...
Oh, there's...
That's the tournament organizer.
And then you can gift them roses.
And then there's...
Wait, there's bonds.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then...
You increase your bond.
I forget where the other page is.
There's another page where you can like marry someone.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
What?
Oh, it's the connection.
There's soulmate, close friend, and partner.
Yeah, soulmate.
There you go.
You can have one soulmate.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
We got five partners?
What the hell?
Yo, polygamy.
Wait, but like what are the benefits of having a soulmate?
You get trial points.
But like, what does that mean?
It's points for...
Oh my god.
Oh, it's for the rolls?
This game is gonna be the next e-dating mess.
Oh, is it for rolls?
Guys, if you find your soulmate, you get to have more points for gacha.
Really?
Guys, it's all...
Do it for your anime waifus.
Find your soulmate.
That's crazy.
There's gonna be Twitter drama over this shit.
Yeah, there is.
I wonder if people were randomly adding us earlier.
They were all trying...
People were randomly adding us when we were playing Quick Play.
Really?
Yeah.
No, I think those were friend recommendations.
Yeah, they're trying to get like...
Uh...
Trial points.
No, I think it just recommends that every time.
Really?
Oh.
Alright, well...
GG's guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
That was great, guys.
Yeah.
I had fun being a double agent.
Yeah, you did.
I think I was a double agent.
I won't see you tomorrow.
I was just eating dirt.
I'd expect nothing less.
Get it!
Yay!
You know, if we lived...
Good-bye-ness.
If we lived for like three more teams, we could have been top six.
Type shit.
Yeah.
Or if I didn't get knocked.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, yeah.
That's true.
We got knocks instead.
I was last to get knocked the second round.
That's what matters.
If Sherfer wasn't throwing...
I would be doing something wrong.
Actually, I was last to get knocked.
Nobody resed me when I got knocked.
Nobody resed me.
Everybody...
First to curse us.
Everybody just watched me crawl away, the support player.
Instead of resing me.
That's all I'm going to say.
I tried.
Then I got gunned.
That's life's time.
I could have been resed two minutes ago.
Goodbye.
GG's.
Leave.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.
I'll stay in the server.
Is this part of the experiment?
I get...
This is my VC chat now.
Yeah.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
I had a great time with...
Surefire, Mac, and RPR.
It was...
I hope you guys had a fun time watching as well.
I'm free on Sunday.
Yay.
My vacation starts tomorrow.
Yippee.
But that was really fun.
I was mostly a heal bot, but...
I felt like I had to.
Like, I literally could not do anything but heal.
Because every time they peaked, I had to, like, press Q.
Yay.
Vacation starts tomorrow.
But I had a fun time.
It was a fun time checking out this game.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching with us.
And enjoyed watching our adventure today with everyone.
And...
Please feel free to check out the game right now.
You can wishlist it.
I hope that some of you guys were able to get keys for the closed beta.
You can wishlist the game on Steam right now by clicking on the link pinned in my chat.
A huge shout out to Faith Trigger for sponsoring all of us.
Sponsoring me, Shur4, RPR, and MAC for the tournament.
It was a great time checking the game out.
And I hope you guys had a fun time.
I know I said that a lot.
But I really hope you guys had a fun time watching.
Anyway, guys.
For those who are new here.
My name is DogiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So, please check me out there.
If you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch.
Please follow me on Twitter.
Because I usually tweet out whenever I'm online on Twitch.
If you want to support me via other means.
Check out my merch.
I have my ramen collab out now for a Doki blade.
A real ass cooking knife.
And I have some stuff you can pre-order or buy right now on my personal store.
The Doki merch store.
Hey guys!
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause to check out when we're around to get that blood flow.
And you sail for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!